COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING EVERYONE IN
RESPONSE TO COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING MPS
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS A
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. FOR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR CORPSMAN BEGINNER
HEARING. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE SENATE
GALLERY TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
PARTICIPATE HE TESTIFIED TODAY.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL ALSO
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
1-844-291-4185 ACCESS CODE. FOUR
SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED. BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THING ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT. WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE A NEEDED ANYWHERE.
WILL NOW BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY. OR THE PHONE
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL ALSO
MAINTAIN DECORUM. DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. MEMBERS WE
HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS. OF
MISTER CHIEF CONSULTANT LET'S
PLEASE ESTABLISH. A QUORUM CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EDITOR'S GONZALEZ. HERE PRESS
CENTER BASED. IT'S HERE THE L.
THEN- ARCHULETA BARTLETT HERE
SENATOR BAKER. SENATE CORTESE.
FOUR DAYS A YEAR SENATOR DOLLY.
FINNA DOT. START HERE THE CENTER
OF THE MALL GREAT. CAN ACQUIRE.
THE NORMAL AND THAT'S- SENATOR
MAN. SENATOR NEWMAN THE MEN HERE
. THE REBEL. THAT- SCANNER. SIR
MY CASKET CASKET PRESENT CENTER
WILL. WHAT PRESENT. ALL RIGHT
WERE ONE SHY OF A QUORUM SO WILL
BE WILL CONTINUE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THEN WE WILL-
INSURE THAT WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM ONCE WE RECEIVE WE INSURE ANOTHER MEMBERS HERE ACTION
OTHER MEMBER HAS COME IN SENATOR
MEN THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WILL CALL
THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME. THERE
ALAN. CENTRE BACK- THE DALAI MON
THEN ACQUIRE THIRD MELINDA'S
SENATOR MEN MEN PRESENT CENTER
RUBIO UNDER SCANNER BUILT ONE
THANK YOU MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE BILL
ON OUR CONSENT FILE FILE ITEM S.
ONE WHICH IS S. B. EIGHT THIRTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR UMBERG IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT FILE BY
SENATOR WILK THANK YOU
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT FILE. ON THE
CONSENT FILE WHICH IS S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN. GONZALEZ HI
AS WELL AS A HIGH STAKES HI
BATES HI ALAN. SUCH A LETTER HI
ARCHULETA I. BECKER. CORTESE
CORTESE I. DALI. DOT BUT I THE
MOMENT. MCGUIRE BELINDA'S MAN
MAN HIGH HUMAN NEWMAN HI RUBIO.
SKINNER WHY CASKEY WHY CASKEY I
WILL WILL GUY. MY FOLKS OKAY WE
HAVE NINE SO FAR FOR CONSENT
FILE WILL ENSURE THAT WE LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON- FIRST WE'LL
START WITH A LITTLE BIT OUT OF
ORDER OR ACTUALLY START WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE BY
SENATOR. NEWMAN. BUT JONES
APOLOGY. OKAY MY APOLOGIES I GOT
THAT MIXED UP WE'RE STARTING
WITH SENATOR JONES WE'RE GONNA
GO RIGHT DOWN THE FILE THE
NUMBER OF FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SP EIGHT NINETY FOUR SENATOR
JONES OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
SENATOR JONES WELCOME AND PLEASE
PRESENT THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIRMAN
I THINK THE APOLOGIES ARE MINE
FOR- CAUSING THE CONFUSION IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO. I THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TODAY
I'M GOING TO BE PRESENTING
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY FOUR
WHICH WILL REQUIRE COMPETITION
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLES TO BE
REGISTERED IN ORDER TO RIDE ON
PUBLIC LANDS URRENTLY
COMPETITION THE MODELS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND OTHER ARE
REGISTERED THROUGH CARBS RED
STICKER PROGRAM THREE YEARS AGO
CAR DECIDED TO END THIS RED
STICKER PROGRAM AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND NO OTHER AGENCY
PUT TOGETHER A PLAN TO REPLACE
THE PROGRAM. THEREFORE
COMPETITION ALWAYS V. MODELS
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND NEWER HAVE
NO WAY TO REGISTER. WITH THE
DMV. MEANWHILE OTHER MODELS TO
STILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY JUST-
UNDER THE RED STICKER PROGRAM.
THIS GAP LEAVES RIDERS WITHOUT
THE NECESSARY DOCUMENTATION THAT
IS REQUIRED FOR A DEALER TO
FINANCE A NEW PURCHASE. OR FOR
AN OWNER TO SECURE INSURANCE.
ADDITIONALLY LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
NOT ABLE TO TRACK TRACE AND SITE
ILLEGAL AND ROGO H. V. WRITING.
OF THESE NEWER MODELS. THIS THE
NEW MODELS CAME ON THE MARKET
THE OAG COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
THROWN INTO CONFUSION. WITH
REPORTS OF. SOME BEING
WRONGFULLY DENIED FOR
REGISTRATION AND SOME BEING
WRONGFULLY APPROVED FOR
REGISTRATION. WITH OR WITHOUT
THIS BILL COMPETITION WHICH V.
RIDING ON PUBLIC LANDS WILL BE
RESTRICTED TO CLOSE COURSES.
THIS BILL MAY LOOK FAMILIAR TO
THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT THIS
IS THE THIRD AND I HOPE THIRD
TIME IS A CHARM- BRING HIS BILL-
TO COMMITTEE. WE HAVE- SPENT
THREE YEARS WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING- ISSUE
COMPETITION ORGANIZATIONS- AG
MANUFACTURES AND SEVERAL STATE
AGENCIES TO CRAFT A REGISTRATION
PROGRAM THAT WORKS FOR EVERYONE.
SINCE THIS BILL WAS LAST SEEN BY
THIS COMMITTEE IT HAS TAKEN
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVED ALL
PREVIOUS OPPOSITION. AND WE DO
NOT EXPECT ANY NEW OPPOSITION TO
CROP UP THIS YEAR. AS THE A.
NINETY FOUR HAS STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I'LL BE
CROSSING AMENDMENTS TODAY TO ADD
SENATORS FURTADO AND WAY SO. AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY AS CO
AUTHORS AND ANYBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST TO BE A CO
AUTHOR TODAY I WOULD LOVE TO ADD
AS WELL. ASK YOUR I'LL VOTE ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND YOU HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FIRST- IS
MISTER DON AMADOR WITH AMA
DISTRICT THIRTY SIX WAS IN
PERSON HERE MR AMADOR. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DON AMADOR
AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN MOTORCYCLIST
ASSOCIATION. DISTRICT THIRTY SIX
AN ORGANIZATION THAT SANCTIONS
FAMILY ORIENTED AMATEUR
COMPETITION MOTORCYCLE EVENTS
THAT OCCUR IN BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE LANDS IN CALIFORNIA. AS
YOU KNOW CAR BENDED THE RED
STICKER PROGRAM IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WITH NO REGISTRATION
PROGRAM PLAN TO REPLACE IT. FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO MODEL YEAR
NEWER COMPETITION BIKES. DESPITE
THE FACT THAT NEWER COMPETITION
SO MODELS ARE STILL AVAILABLE
FOR PURCHASE IN CALIFORNIA. I
HAVE WITNESSED THE CHAOS CREATED
BY THAT DECISION WHERE WE NOW
HAVE AN ENTIRE CLASS THE VOICE
OF REASON HAVE NO REGISTRATION
OR IDENTIFYING DETAILS THAT MAKE
IT IMPOSSIBLE. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO IDENTIFY THE
VEHICLE WHICH CAN LEAD TO
ILLEGAL USING CLOSED OR
SENSITIVE AREAS OR TRESPASS ON
PRIVATE PROPERTY. WITHOUT SP
EIGHT NINE FOUR OWNERS OF THOSE
VEHICLES ARE NO LONGER REQUIRED.
TO RIDE WITH THE SELF COMPLIANT
MUFFLER THAT COMPLIES WITH THE
TWO THOUSAND THREE CALIFORNIA
WHICH WE STILL LAW A LAW THAT I
PROBABLY HELPED CREATE AND
SUPPORT. WITHOUT S. B. EIGHT
NINE FOUR OWNERS OF THOSE
VEHICLES ARE NOW NO LONGER
REQUIRED. TO WRITE A PARK
ARRESTERS IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
NOW HAVE. THE YEAR LONG FIRE
SEASON. WITHOUT S. B. EIGHT NINE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT
HAVE THE DMV REGISTRATION
NECESSARY TO CITE ILLEGAL AND
ROGUE WRITERS. THERE IS A REASON
WHY A NUMBER OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT THE BILL
THAT IS BECAUSE IT WILL CONTINUE
REVENUE STREAMS FOR CONSERVATION
. RESTORATION AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. LOCAL POLICE AND
COUNTY SHERIFFS WILL ONCE AGAIN
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THESE
VEHICLES FOR TRACKING INTO
FORCING SAFE PRACTICES THE
DISTRICT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
YES VOTE BY THE COMMITTEE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR OUTDOOR
ANNEX WE HAVEIN PERSON TERRY
MCHALE WITH COALITION FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TERRY
MCHALE IN THERE AND READING THIS
ESSAY THAT. REPRESENTING THE
COALITION FOR PUBLIC ACCESS- MR
CHEN'S ANALYSIS IS SIXTEEN AND
ACCURATE THE NARRATIVE EXPLAINS.
THAT WHILE THE RED STICKER IS
DISAPPEARED THERE'S STILL THE
NEED FOR THE COMPETITION STICKER
. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES THE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS THE O. H. P.
WRITERS CAME TOGETHER AND
CREATED THE O. H. P. COMMISSION.
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THE PEOPLE COULD RIDE LEGALLY
AND SAFELY AND RESPONSIBLY. AND
WHAT SENATOR JONES HAS IN THIS
BILL IS A MOVEMENT BACK IN THAT
DIRECTION. WE CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO GET THIS
DONE. THE ISSUES ARE CLEAR IT'S
BEEN STATED WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
THANK YOU MR MCHALE SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SO NOW WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
SENATE GALLERY WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. SB EIGHT
NINETY FOUR PLEASE. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB MY APOLOGIES MR
MODERATOR- I WILL START WITH THE
GALLERY IN PERSON HERE AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO- THE
TELECONFERENCE MY APOLOGIES.
IT'LL BE THE SENSATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY OF SB EIGHT
NINETY FOUR. OKAY C. NONE THEN
WE WILL MOVE ON NOW TO OUR
MODERATOR WHO HAS- FOLKS QUEUED
UP VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT NINETY FOUR WE WILL BEGIN
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
HAD TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB
EIGHT NINE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THE OPERATOR WILL QUICKLY GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER I FIND A PLACE
RIGHT BACK IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO. TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT NINETY FOUR.
AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP.
FIRST PARTICIPANT WILL BE QUITE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CAPITALIST
REPRESENTING ME OFF ROAD VEHICLE
LEGISLATIVE COALITION A
STATEWIDE CONSUMER ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR
DILIGENCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING NICHOLAS
HARRIS WESTERN STATES
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE AMERICAN
MOTORCYCLIST ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINE FOUR. AND NEXT IS- ONE
MOMENT WE'RE GETTING THEIR LINE
NUMBERS I WILL GO TO ONE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT YEAH
I'M IN TOTAL SUPPORT. I THINK IT
WILL TAKE- ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE VIA TELECONFERENCE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT NINETY FOUR
PLEASE. AND NEXT IS LYING TWELV
YOUR OPEN. YOUR BRAND TO YOUR
CAR MOTORCYCLE PERFORMANCE
CENTER ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA-
KEEP HERE MARLBORO DEALER. AND
I'M TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONLY
ONE WITH A LIFE THIRTEEN YOUR
OPEN. NINE THIRTY PLEASE ON MUTE. NINE THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. I
WILL MOVE ON THAT TWO LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JEAN TURNER I'M A JOURNALIST
AND THEY OFFER A MOTORCYCLE
INDUSTRY AND I SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION. AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB
EIGHT NINE FOUR. BY FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS PATRICK
AIR CANADA YOUR UP FOR THE TRAIN
CALLING AT THE PORT OF SENATE
BILL NINETY FOUR THANK YOU. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE ELEVEN YOUR
OPEN- MY WORK FROM ONE ACCOUNT
FOR QPR MINNESOTA'S PORTABLE.
NINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING- MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS RESTAURANT
IN WITH CALIFORNIA VOTERS
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NINE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
THIS IS JUST LIKE A MOCK ONE
MOTORSPORT HONDA YAMAHA KTM
HUSKY I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL.
M. MEDICARE WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS MODERATOR- WE'VE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF THE
TELECONFERENCE AND WE'VE-
EXHAUSTED ALL OF OUR SUPPORTERS
AT THIS TIME SO FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD OFFICE-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SENATOR
JONES SO WILL GO HEAD TO MOVE-
ON TO ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINETY FOUR C. NINE. MR
MODERATOR DO HAVE ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WHO'D LIKE
TO PARTICIPATE IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHT NINETY FOUR PLEASE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO A NINETY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BEGIN TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR BILL SB EIGHT
NINE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MADAM CHAIR NOBODY IS KILLING
UP AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR- SO NOW WE'LL TAKE
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS I
SEE SENATOR ARCHULETA. BEST
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I'D LIKE
TO COMPLIMENT TO THE AUTHOR
WHOSE WORK WORK VERY WELL WITH
EVERYONE AND- THE ENVIRONMENT
PUBLIC SAFETY EVERYTHING HAS
BEEN- ADJUSTED SO NOW WE HAVE A
TERRIFIC BILL AND I WOULD- LIKE
TO MOVE IT. IT ALSO BE A CO
AUTHOR. GREAT THANK YOU WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR ARCHULETA I
SEE ANOTHER MAKES UP SENATOR
JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS BILL
WILL PRESENT MANY ENVIRONMENTAL
AND ENFORCEMENT BENEFITS. WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR A SPARK
ARRESTOR AS SOUND MUFFLER. AND
WITH THE ABILITY FOR ENFORCEMENT
TO CITE ILLEGAL WRITING. I ASKED
I THANK YOU FOR THE- ATTENTION
THIS MORNING THE CO AUTHORS AND
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES AND I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS AS WELL WITH
OUR COMMITTEE. THANK YOU- SO
THIS IS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON ESPN
NINETY FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RIVER. AND RIVER
FOR THE TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER.
SENATORS GONZALEZ HI
ANTHOLOGIZED. BATES HI EIGHT HI
ALAN. ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I
BECKER. POTATO CORTESE I FELL
KELLY HI DOT. DONNA HI THE
MOBILE. WHY ARE. WELL IN THIS.
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I RUBIO
RUBIO I CAN. SKINNER HI BY
CASKEY BY KELSEY I WILL BOOK HI. OKAY OKAY WE HAVE TWELVE EYES
IT LOOKS LIKE IT HAS ENOUGH TO
GET OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES NOW MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
NINE FORTY TWO BY SENATOR NEWMAN
WELCOME. AT THE MEETINGS AND-
MANAGING MONEY MANAGER AND
MEMBERS. THAT I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SP NINE FORTY TWO WHICH
WILL PROVIDE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES. THE
AUTHORIZATION OF FLEXIBILITY TO
UTILIZE FUNDS UNDER CALIFORNIA'S
LOW CARBON. TRANSIT OPERATIONS
PROGRAM OFTEN REFERRED TO AS L.
C. TUB. TO SUPPORT FREE OR
REDUCED FARE TRANSIT PROGRAMS.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS. THE
APPLICATION OF LC TOP FUNDS IN
THIS MANNER WILL PROVIDE FOR THE
LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY AND
BENEFITS. OF FORWARD THINKING
TRANSIT PROGRAMS SUCH AS FREE
AND REDUCED FAIR. USE RUSSIAN
PROGRAMS THAT EXPAND ACCESS TO
PUBLIC TRANSIT. AND CREATE
LIFELONG TRANSIT RIDERS WHILE
REDUCING. GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS LC TOP WHICH REGION
CREATED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN BY S.
B.EIGHT SIXTY TWO. AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF
PROGRAMS TARGETING GHG.
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. USING FUNDS
GENERATED BY THE STATE'S
GROUNDBREAKING CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNSTABLE
COMMUNITIES TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL AND
OPERATING PROJECTS. AND HIGH
SPEED RAIL LC TOP IS A MINISTER
BY CALTRANS. AND IS FUNDED
THROUGH A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION OF FIVE PERCENT.
OF GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDS GENERATED BY CAP AND
TRADE. FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. WAS SLATED FOR
ALLOCATION. TO LC TOP. AS NOTED
ONE OF THE FOUNDATION
FOUNDATIONAL GOALS OF LC TOP IS
THE PROVISION OF OPERATING AND
CAPITAL SYSTEMS. TO TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO IMPROVE MOBILITY
WHILE REDUCING GHGS WITH A
PRIORITY ON SERVING
DISADVANTAGED. COMMUNITIES
TODAY'S BILL BUILDS ON SP ELEVEN
NINETEEN PASSING TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHICH CONTAIN PROVISIONS FOR
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO INVEST LC
TOP FUNDS. IN THREE AREAS
PURSUANT TO MEETING THE OVERALL
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT. OF
PROVIDING A BENEFIT. TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THOSE
THREE AREAS WERE. ONE FUNNY
TRANSIT FARE SUBSIDIES INCLUDING
STUDENT TRANSIT PASSES. TO FUNNY
TRANSIT CONNECTIONS TO MAJOR
EMPLOYMENT AREAS EDUCATION
CENTERS OR MEDICAL FACILITIES
FOR RESIDENTS OF DISADVANTAGED
OR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. OR
THREE FUNNY TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT REDUCE
EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE. GASES
INCLUDING THE APPLICATION ELSE
THE TOP FIVE FOR THE PER. OF
ZERO BUSES AND FUELING IN FOR.
UNDER THE PROVISION OF SB ELEVEN
NINETEEN TRANSIT AGENCY CAN ONLY
USE LC TOP FUNDS ONCE PER SIX
MONTH PROGRAM INTERVAL MEANING
THAT THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
REAPPLY IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO
ADMINISTER AN APPROVED PROGRAM.
EVEN IF THE POPULATION SERVED
HAS NOT CHANGED BECAUSE THE
PROGRAM REQUIRES REGULAR
RIGOROUS EMISSION REDUCTION
ANALYSIS AND OTHER REPORTING
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS WHILE
ALLOWING FOR LONGER PERIODS OF
APPROVAL THEREBY EXTENDING AND
EXPANDING. THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAM OVER THE PAST DECADE
ESPECIALLY IN A PANDEMIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
HAS STRIVED TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT FREE AND REDUCED
TRANSFER PROGRAMS. UNFORTUNATELY
A LACK OF AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR
ME TO ANY PROGRAMS ON A LONG
TERM BASIS HAS STYMIED THOSE
EFFORTS. IN ORANGE COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY HAS
SUCCESSFULLY OPERATED LC TOUGH
FUNDED YOUTH RIDE FREE PROGRAM
ALLOWING YOUNG WRITERS AGES
EIGHTEEN AND UNDER TO ACCESS ALL
ORANGE COUNTY FIXED ROUTE BUSES.
AT NO COST THIS SIX MONTH POLICY
TOP PILOT BEGINNING SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH PASSES
THAT WERE VALID THROUGH FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH OF THIS YEAR.
SINCE THE PROGRAM'S INCEPTION
THE NUMBER OF YOUTH RIDERS HAS
INCREASED STEADILY FROM SEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TO OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
RIDERS IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE COMPELLING EVIDENCE
THAT THE PROGRAM IS SUCCEEDING
IN ITS AIM OF CULTIVATING A
GENERATION OF NEW AND HOPEFULLY
LIFELONG WRITER. IS PROMISING IF
RUSSIA PROGRAM HAS ALSO PROVIDED
A SECONDARY BENEFIT OF
SUPPORTING ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
ORANGE COUNTY IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC. PARTICULARLY AMONG
ORANGE COUNTY'S LOW INCOME AND
DIVERSE POPULATIONS
UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER WHILE THE
INITIAL PILOT PROGRAM QUALIFIED
TO UTILIZE LC TOP FUNDING. THE
EXISTING STATUTORY RESTRICTIONS
NOTED EARLIER RENDER LC TOP AN
UNSUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF ONGOING
FUNDING IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
INITIAL SUCCESS FOR LONG TERM
PROSPECTS AND BENEFITS OF THIS
PROGRAM. UPON PASSAGE OF ANTI
BEST BE NINE FORTY TWO
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT AGENCY WILL
BE AUTHORIZED TO USE LC TOP
MONIES FOR THE FUNDING OF FREE.
OR REDUCED FARE TRANSIT PROGRAMS
AND TO CONTINUE TO USE THOSE FOR
TO MAKE THOSE PRO. ON AN
ONGOING. PROVIDED THAT THE
POPULATION OR OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THE PROGRAM HAVE NOT CHANGED IN
SO DOING S. B. NINE FORTY TWO
WILL PROVIDE MULTIPLE
SIMULTANEOUS BENEFITS. REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GREENHOUSE GASES
EXPANDING MASS TRANSIT
UTILIZATION BY CREATIVE LIFELONG
WRITERS REDUCING CONGESTION ON
OUR STREETS. AND OFFERING AN
AVENUE FOR ECONOMIC IMPROVEMENT
TO FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS. HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
THIS MORNING- MISTER GERALD
JOHNSON THE C. E. O. OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSIT AUTHORITY.
AND MR MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. FOR A TRIP
TO SUSPICION I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR AN I. VOTE THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN AND TODAY WE HAVE BOTH IN
PERSON AS YOU MENTION MR DALE
TERREL JOHNSON CEO WITH A CTA
THANK YOU. MR JOHNSON. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS EARL
JOHNSON THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. WE'RE
HERE TODAY AS A SPONSOR OF SB
NINE FORTY TWO. BUT CITY AS WELL
AS TRANSIT AGENCIES NATION A
STATE WIDE RECEIVE LOW CARBON
TRANSIT OPERATIONS PROGRAM
FUNDING AS YOU HEARD KNOWN AS LC
TOP. MANUALLY ON A FORMAL BASIS
AND FOR A CTA THAT'S INCLUDED.
AND PROVIDED AT A KEY SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO SUPPORT NEW AND
EXPANDED BUS OR RAIL SERVICE.
WHICH HAS INCLUDED INITIAL USE
OF THESE FUNDS FOR REDUCED OR
FREE TRANSIT FARE PILOT PROGRAMS
WITHIN OUR COUNTY. SAMPLE LC TOP
IS BEEN USED BY OCC FOR COLLEGE
PASS PROGRAM PARTNERING WITH
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANTLY DISCOUNTED
FARE PASSES TO STUDENTS. AND
MOST RECENTLY WE'VE USED OUR
SHARE OF LC TOP FUNDS TO FUND OR
USE RIDE FREE PROGRAM. AS A
PROMOTIONAL PASS THAT ALLOWS
YOUTHS AGE EIGHTEEN UNDER TO
WRITE ALL ORANGE COUNTY FIXED
ROUTE BUSES FOR FREE. THE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL WE HAVE NEARLY SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND TOTAL
BOARDINGS. SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE PROGRAM IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THE
NUMBER OF UNIQUE YOUTH WRITERS
HAS CONTINUED TO INCREASE. THE
YOUTH RIDE FREE PROGRAMS A KEY
PART OF THE STRATEGY TO IMPROVE
MOBILITY OPTIONS REDUCE
CONGESTION. AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WITHIN
ORANGE COUNTY. IN ADDITION IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN BRINGING
RIDERSHIP LEVELS BACK WHAT WE
HAD PRIOR TO THE KOBE PANDEMIC.
DUE TO THE SUCCESS THE- CITY
BOARD OF DIRECTORS DIRECTORS
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO MAKE THIS
PROGRAM PERMANENT AND EXPANDED
TO INCLUDE. PARA TRANSIT RIDERS
AS WELL THAT ARE ALSO EIGHTEEN
AND UNDER. IN ADDITION- WITH IN
TAKING THIS ACTION OUR BOARD
IDENTIFIED LC TOP FUNDING IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE WE CAN KEEP
THE PROGRAM IN PLACE.
UNFORTUNATELY AS YOU'VE HEARD
THAT INITIAL PILOT PROGRAM
QUALIFIED TO USE LC TOP FUNDING.
BUT IT CANNOT BE USED TO FUND
THE PROGRAM LONG TERM REGARDLESS
OF ITS SUCCESS. SB NINE FORTY
TWO WILL CLARIFY THE ONGOING USE
OF LC TOP FUNDING FOR THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS AUTHORIZED.
ALLOWING TRANS AGENCY SUCH AS A
CTA TO SUSTAIN OUR CURRENT
PROGRAMS. AGENCIES WILL STILL BE
REQUIRED TO REPORT ON METRICS
ASSOCIATE WITH THE PAST
PROGRAMS. AND DEMONSTRATE
CONSISTENCY WITH LC TOP
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS IN THE
INITIAL ALLOCATION REQUEST.
WITHOUT A COMPLETE MY
PRESENTATION AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JOHNSON. NEXT
TO MY MISTER MICHAEL PIMENTEL
WITH CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF MICHAEL PIMENTEL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATION
THE ASSOCIATION. IS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB NINE FOUR TWO. I
JOIN YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY
MORE THAN EIGHTY FIVE TRANSFER
REALLY AGENCY MEMBERS TO VOICE
OUR STRONG SUPPORT. FOR SB NINE
FOURTEEN AND RESPECTFULLY URGE I
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL. AS
YOU HEARD SENATOR NEWMAN AND MR
JOHNSON DESCRIBE THIS BILL WOULD
AUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
AGENCIES. TO CONTINUOUSLY
DIRECTOR LOW CARBON
TRANSFORMATION PROGRAM FUNDS.
THE FAIR OR REDUCED TRANSIT FARE
PROGRAMS. NOW THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE PROVEN TO BE QUITE POPULAR-
BUT WE HAVE FOUND STATEWIDE THE
TRANSIT AGENCIES OFTEN HAVE
DIFFICULTY SUSTAINING. THESE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY INHERENTLY
REDUCE REVENUES COLLECTED AT THE
FARE BOX. NOW THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS HAVE
OVERCOME THIS CHALLENGE BY
IDENTIFYING LONG TERM FUNDING
SUPPORT. INCLUDING FROM FOR
EXAMPLE UNIVERSITY LEVEL
ASSESSMENTS IN COUNTY GENERAL
FUNDS. NO S. B. NINE FOUR TWO
WOULD CREATE AN ADDITIONAL
PATHWAY TO LONG TERM FUNDING
SUPPORT FOR THESE PROGRAMS. BY
MY EARLY MODIFYING THE EXISTING
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. WHICH WAS DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE OPERATIONAL
INVESTMENTS THAT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
DELIVER BENEFITS TO
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. IF PASSED WE
BELIEVE THIS WILL NOT ONLY
BENEFIT TRANSIT AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITIES WITH PROGRAMS IN
PLACE TODAY. BUT ALSO TRANSIT
AGENCIES AND COMMUNITIES ON THE
VERGE OF CREATING SUCH PROGRAMS.
IN DOING SO THIS BILL WOULD
SUPPORT OUR INDUSTRY AND OUR
EFFORTS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO OUR
SERVICES. WHILE ALSO PROTECTING
THE FINANCIAL HEALTH OF OUR
TRANSIT AGENCIES WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
MORNING AND ENCOURAGE. PRIVATE
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR PATEL. WE'VE
CONCLUDED OUR LEAD WITNESS
TESTIMONY AND NOW WE MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN THE GALLERY. IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FOUR TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BUT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE SAME
OKAY TRANSIT. AS WELL AS
MONTEREY SALINAS TRANSIT IN
SUPPORT. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE FORTY
TWO IN THE GALLERY. CASEY NONE.
NOW MOVE ON TO THE MODERATOR- IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FOUR TWO PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
FOUR TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOT FREE WILL
QUICKLY GIVE ME YOUR LINE
NUMBER. IN PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE LINE
TWENTY FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING THE WALL COMING UP
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
NYC TRANSIT. ABOUT CHARACTER OR
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR SB NINE FOUR TWO. I'M SURE
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FOUR TWO WILL
MOVE OVER TO- ANY OPPOSITION AND
LOOKS LIKE YOU DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION- IN TERMS OF
WITNESSES SO WE'LL MOVE TO THE
GALLERY IS THERE ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE FORTY TWO. THE NUN WILL
MOVE ON TO. YES MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE ANYBODY IN A BID ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
FORTY TWO POLICE. SORRY ABOUT
THAT I JUMPED THE GUN A LITTLE
BIT YOU ARE OKAY THE FRONT.
THANK YOU I PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINETY FOUR TO. YEAH MAN
I'M SURE NOBODY'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH I WOULD CONCLUDE BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION SO WE'LL
TAKE IT TO BACK TO MEMBERS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. REGARDING SB NINE FORTY
TWO SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I DO THINK THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL THE WAY
I SEE IT IT'S A WIN WIN.
SITUATION PROGRAMS LIKE THESE
ARE NEEDED TO IMPROVE MOBILITY
BUT SPECIFICALLY IT ALSO HELPS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND-
AND THAT'S GREAT AND WHILE
HELPING THE ENVIRONMENT SO. NOT
ONLY DO I WANT TO MOVE THE BILL
BUT I WANT TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR I THINK THAT DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES WHERE- YOU KNOW
A LOT OF FOLKS CAN'T AFFORD THE
GAS NOR. COULD THEY AFFORD TO-
TO PAY FOR A CAR THIS IS A GREAT
WAY TO GET PEOPLE TO INCREASE
RIDERSHIP CELL WITH THAT I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO SENATOR
AKOWSKI. MADAM CHAIR THIS. THE
STAFF REPORT INDICATES THAT THIS
PROGRAM THE 5% THAT COMES AT A
CAP AND TRADE. WOULD BE WAS.
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FISCAL. TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THEN.
I'M DOING CALCULATIONS WE'VE HAD
THREE QUARTERS OF THE- OF THE
CAP AND TRADE AUCTIONS FOR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND WE'RE
ALREADY AT THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION. M. WITHIN MINUTES HIS
PAINTED OTHER BILLION IN THE-
MAY AUCTION. MY CALCULATION IS
THAT MONEY THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES
25% WOULD BE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY.
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS IS QUITE A
BIT MORE THAN EIGHTY TWO
MILLION. I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
. IF HE IF NINE FOUR TWO BECOMES
LAW MAYBE. THE EITHER THE
AUTHOR. OR MR PIMENTEL WHAT
OTHER AGENCIES MIGHT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS CONTINUING.
APPROPRIATION AT THE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR LEVEL THAT
ARE TAKING PLACE. THERE ARE-
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
POPULAR. AND- POPULAR PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE SHRINKING
PASSENGER- PARTICIPATION ON OUR
TRANSITS GIVEN THE PART THAT
MAKES- THEY THINK THE LOW
NUMBERS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
OUR COVERT RELATED BUT I'M
CURIOUS IF THEY SEE THE CHANGES
THAT ARE PROPOSED IN SB NINE
FOUR TWO AS IGNITING OTHER. OF
THE- TRANSLATIONS HE SAID ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THAT THEY WOULD
PARTICIPATE. AND WHAT THAT MAY
DO TO RIDERSHIP THANK YOU-
SENATOR NEWMAN AND I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION SO YOU SAID THAT
YOU KNOW THE GOAL OF THE BILL IS
TO ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
LIMITATIONS AGREED BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION. LET ME PLEASE
DEFER TO EITHER MR PIMENTEL OR
MISTER JOHNSON- TO SPEAK ON HOW
OTHER AGENCIES MIGHT ACCESS
THESE FUNDS ABSOLUTELY SENATOR
NEWMAN WE HAVE MR UP UNTIL LINED
UP SO PLEASE MR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO TO SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
USE QUESTION I WOULD WANT TO
NOTE. THAT WHILE THIS PROGRAM
DOES RECEIVE 5% OF THE ONGOING
APPROPRIATION FROM CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM EVERY AGENCY IN THE
STATE DOES RECEIVE A FORMULA
SHARE. INTO THERE IS A PUBLISHED
NOTICE FROM CALTRANS THAT GOES
OUT TO AGENCIES THAT DEFINES HOW
MUCH FROM THIS PROGRAM THEY WILL
RECEIVE AN AGENCIES ARE CHARGED
WITH PUTTING FORWARD. PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS THAT MEET THAT
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS IS THAT
COULD BE INSTANCES OF ALLOWING
AGENCIES TO ADVANCE THEIR FREE
REDUCE TRANSIT FOR PROGRAMS
COULD ALSO BE OTHER OPERATIONAL
INVESTMENTS SIMPLY INCREASING
SERVICE LEVELS FOR EXAMPLE. AND
SO AGENCIES WILL MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON THE APPROPRIATIONS THAT
ARE PROVIDED IN THEIR EXACT
FORMULA SHARED A WE WOULD
STIPULATE THAT WITH THIS. NEW
FLEXIBILITY THAT IS PROPOSED IN
SB NINE FOUR TWO MORE AGENCIES
WILL BE INCLINED TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH FAIR OR REDUCED TRANSFER
PROGRAMS RECOGNIZING THAT THEY
COULD- PURSUE THOSE PROGRAMS IN
PERPETUITY WITHOUT THE THREAT OF
A RECESSION. AND SO THAT I THINK
IS AN EQUITABLE REALLY JUST
ENCOURAGING THE INDUSTRY FORWARD
ON THE ACCESS ISSUE- THAT'S
PROVIDED BY THE SPILL OVER TO
SPARK PASSES. THANK YOU MISTER
PRIME INTEL AND I THINK- I DON'T
KNOW IF ANYONE ELSE QUEUED UP
PROBABLY NOT. THE SENATOR NEWMAN
ADD TO IT THANK YOU TO MUCH
MIDDLE ELEVEN LET E ALSO THAT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE SOURCES- FORD
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES- THEY'RE VERY LIMITED.
NUMBERS FOR THE USE OF
TRANSCRIBER SO THAT THERE IN
LIES THE BASIS. FOR THIS BILL-
DIVIDED FLEXIBILITY IT YOU KNOW
THANK YOU. TO BOTH OF THE
WITNESSES- FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION- GRATEFUL TO
SENATOR RUBIO GLAD TO ADD YOU.
AS A CO AUTHOR- BY EXTENDING AND
EXPANDING LC TOP PROGRAMS S. B.
NINE FOUR TO ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL GOALS FOR
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES WHILE.
SUPPORTING INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
TO EXPANDING MASS TRANSIT
OPTIONS PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO
WILL BENEFIT THE MOST- AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO IN THE
AFTERMATH OF ENDEMIC ARE MOST INNEED WITH THAT. I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN I
SEE NO OTHER MIKES UP BUT- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR RUBIO
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU AS
WELL FOR THIS A BILL I KNOW
THAT- CTA HAS BEEN A GREAT JOB
IN MAKING INCREDIBLE. BUSINESS
CASE BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
ENSURING THAT THERE'S RIDERSHIP-
AFTER THESE PROTRACTED THAT THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY INSTITUTED
HAVE. HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
SO THAT SHOULD MR CHIEF
CONSULTANT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR RUBIO. ON S. B. NINE
FORTY TWO. ON S. B. NINE FORTY
TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. SENATORS
GONZALEZ HI IN DALLAS I HATE. HI
EIGHT HI ALAN. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI BECKER. CORTESE
CORTESE II DOLLY. DOT HI THE
MOMENT. WHERE MELINDA'S MAN MAN
I KNOW MAN HI NEWMAN I REVEAL
RUBIO I SCANNER. CASKEY I WOKE
WELCOME HI. OKAY THAT HAS ELEVEN
EYES IT LOOKS LIKE IT HAS ENOUGH
TO GET OUT BELIEVE THAT ON CALL
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN NOW MOVE ON TO
THE SENATE- SENATOR DODD WITH
FILE ITEM FOR S. P. TEN FORTY
NINE SENATOR DODD WELCOME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA HAS FOR MANY
YEARS LED THE NATION WITH OUR
AGGRESSIVE EFFORTS TO COMBAT
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR DRIVEN
CLIMATE CHANGE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO LEAD ON
BUILDING A MORE RESILIENT FUTURE
AN SP TEN FORTY NINE WOULD PAVE
THE WAY. S. B. TEN FORTY NINE
WOULD ESTABLISH THE
TRANSPORTATION RESILIENCE
PROGRAM THE FUND CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PLANNING AND
PROJECTS. TO IMPROVE THE
RESILIENCE OF ROADS BRIDGES
TRANSIT ANOTHER CRITICAL
TRANSPORTATION ASSETS THAT ARE
AT RISK FROM CLIMATE CHANGE. IT
ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS ARE
COMMUNITIES ARE SEEING THE
IMPACTS OF AN ALREADY CHANGING
CLIMATE. FROM FLOODING TO
EXTREME CLIMATE FUELED NATURAL
HAZARDS ARE THREATENING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS- THERE ARE
CONSTITUENTS DEPEND ON TO GET TO
WORK GO TO THE DOCTOR AND MOVE
GOODS IN AND OUT OF OUR PORTS.
IT MIGHT IN SENATOR MCGUIRE'S
DISTRICT STATE ROUTE THIRTY
SEVEN IS ONE OF THOSE LIFELINES
THAT THE NEXT TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS IS EXPECTED TO BE UNDER
WATER. YES THREE TEN FORTY NINE
LAYS THE GROUNDWORK FOR MAJOR
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS BY
DEDICATING RESOURCES TO START
IMPLEMENTING HIGH PRIORITY
RESILIENCE IMPROVEMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED THROUGH ROBUST.
MULTI STAKEHOLDER PLANNING. AT
THE SAME TIME MANY COMMUNITIES
MOST IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
ALSO LACKED THE FUNDS TO ENGAGE
IN THE CRITICAL PLANNING WORK
NEEDED TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
TRANSPORTATION ASSETS AS WELL AS
ADJACENT COMMUNITIES. S. B. TEN
FORTY NINE INCLUDES DEDICATED
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THIS
PLANNING. RESILIENCY WILL TAKE
MANY FORMS ACROSS THE STATE AS
WE LOOK TO ADDRESS NOT ONLY C.
LEVEL RISE BUT WILDFIRES
MUDSLIDES AND OTHER CLIMATE
FUELED HAZARDS. NO MATTER THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS IN A GIVEN
COMMUNITY ONE THING IS CLEAR
CALIFORNIA WILL REQUIRE LARGE
SCALE INVESTMENT TO PROTECT OUR
TRANSPORTATION ASSETS AND MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES RESILIENT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. I APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS RAISED
IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT-
ESTABLISHING APPROPRIATE PROJECT
CRITERIA AND PRIORITIES AS WELL
AS FUNDING SPLITS BETWEEN
PLANNING VERSUS PROJECTS AND I'D
BE GLAD TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THOSE ISSUES
SHOULD THE BILL MOVE FORWARD
TODAY. I HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH
ME TODAY TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT.
GEORGE AGAIN DORMANT ON BEHALF
OF THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
INSOUCIANCE SMITH FROM THE
CINEMA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD- YES WE'LL START WITH YOUR-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY NINE WILL START WITH
GEORGIA AGAIN DORMANT WITH MTC
THANK YOU. HI I'M GOOD MORNING
I'M GEORGE AGAIN DOORMEN I'M AT
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WE ARE THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
FINANCING AND COORDINATING
AGENCY FOR THE NINE COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. I WE'RE
SPONSORING SB TEN FORTY NINE
WHICH WOULD FOR THE FIRST TIME
CREATE A DEDICATED RELIABLE FUN
SOURCE FOR CALIFORNIA. THE
DOCTOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES TO THE ALREADY
CHANGING CLIMATE. THIS BILL
WOULD DIRECT THE CTC TO DEDICATE
A PORTION OF THE STATE'S THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
HIGHWAY FUNDING. THROUGH THE NEW
TRANSPORTATION RESILIENCE
PROGRAM I WOULD CREATE A
FRAMEWORK FOR STRATEGICALLY
PLANNING FOR AND BUILDING
RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE. SO
COUPLE KEY POINTS- FIRST THE
BILL WOULD PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
RESOURCES TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTING
A PRESSING ADAPTATION PRIORITIES
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
IDENTIFIED THROUGH THE ROBUST
MULTI STAKEHOLDER RESILIENCE
PLANNING WORK THAT'S COMMENCED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FROM THE
STATE ROUTE THIRTY SEVEN
RECENTLY QUARTER PROGRAM TO THE
MYRIAD OF S. U. S. SENATE BILL
ONE FUNDED ADAPTATION PLANS-
THERE ARE A WIDE RANGE OF THESE
PLANNING ROBUST MULTI
STAKEHOLDER RESILIENCE PLANS
THAT AGAIN HAVE BEEN I'M GOING
AND HAVE BEEN ADOPTED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE DIRECTION TO THE CD TO
DIRECT FUNDING TO PROTECT HIGH
PRIORITY VULNERABLE
TRANSPORTATION ASSETS AS DEFINED
IN THE BILL. THAT AND THAT WOULD
ALSO HELP REDUCE RISK FOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN PART
TO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT. AT
THE SAME TIME MANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT AS THE SENATOR
SAID THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. ARE REALLY IN
DESPERATE NEED OF FUNDS TO
ENGAGE IN THE CRITICAL PLANNING
WORK UP FRONT. THAT'S NEEDED TO
IDENTIFY ADAPTATION NEEDS AND TO
BEGIN FLESHING OUT SOLUTIONS
THAT NOT ONLY PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE TRANSPORTATION
ASSETS. BUT ALSO THE ADJACENT
COMMUNITIES. AND AGAIN NOT TO
MENTION THE CAPITAL FUNDS TO
CONSTRUCT THOSE PROJECTS. THAT'S%
WHY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT I
SPEAK TEN FORTY NINE INCLUDES
DEDICATED RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
THE PLANNING. BECAUSE THE
PROGRAM TO BE FUNDED FROM
RECURRING FEDERAL FORMULA
DOLLARS THAT COME ITH A HIGH
DEGREE OF CERTAINTY. THOSE
ONGOING PLANNING RESOURCES CAN
HELP T. UP A PROJECT PIPELINE.
SO BEFORE I CLOSE I WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO REFLECT ON HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR STRONG STATE
LEADERSHIP AND DIRECTING REGIONS
AND OTHERS ON THE GROUND TO
BEGIN WRAPPING OUR ARMS AROUND
THIS ENORMOUS AND REALLY
PRESSING NEED- BUT ONE THAT
WE'VE BEEN PUTTING OFF FOR QUITE
A WHILE BECAUSE OF. THAT MANY
MORE IMMEDIATE ISSUES AT HAND.
THE INFLUX OF RESOURCES FROM THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL ON THE HEELS
OF THE HISTORIC SP ONE
INVESTMENT REALLY DOES CREATE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO DEDICATE
RESOURCES TO BEGIN TO TACKLE
THIS MUCH NEEDED- DOWN PAYMENT
ON RESILIENCE. THANKS THANK YOU
MR MAN. NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
MISS SUSAN SMITH WITH THE SCTA
THANK YOU MISS SMITH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SUZANNE SMITH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CINEMA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AND THE CINEMA COUNTY REGIONAL
CLIMATE PROTECTION AUTHORITY.
OUR WORK IS REALLY AT THE
INTERSECTION ALITY OF
TRANSPORTATION AND CLIMATE AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WERE
SO EXCITED AND PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB TEN FORTY NINE. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
JOBS ACT REALLY PROVIDES A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE
TO ADDRESS RESILIENCE AS WELL AS
OUR OTHER PRESSING
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS. AT THREE
TEN FORTY NINE FURTHER PROVIDES
FURTHER OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
OUR PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY IN
ASSESSING AND IDENTIFYING WHERE
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ARE
MOST CRITICALLY IMPACTED BY THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. BY
ALLOCATING A SMALL PORTION OF
THE OVERALL I. I. J. MONEY TO
THE CDC EXPECT TO SEE THE BEST
AND MOST CRITICAL PROJECTS RISE
TO THE TOP THROUGH A VERY.
TRANSPARENT AND PUBLIC PROCESS.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH
BOTH TRADITIONAL PARTNERS AS
WELL AS NONTRADITIONAL PARTNERS
SUCH AS ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE ACTIVE IN
THE FIELD WORKING ON THE EFFECTS
OF THINGS LIKE SEA LEVEL RISE.
THAT STILL RISE. AND THAT WILL
HELP US FIND WAYS TO DELIVER
PROJECTS INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
MORE CREATIVELY AND WITH CO
BENEFITS FOR BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION. AND ADDRESSING THE
- IDIOT IMPACTS TO COMMUTE.
THAT'S TEN FORTY NINE PUTS THE
STATE IN A POSITION TO LEVERAGE
FURTHER FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL AS
LOCAL SOURCES. TO GET THESE KEY
INFRASTRUCTURE RESILIENCE
PROJECTS OUT ON THE STREET
QUICKLY. BY BOLSTERING
PARTNERSHIPS TO ADDRESS
RESILIENCE NEEDS WE WILL BE ABLE
TO SHOWCASE HOW STATES CAN AND
SHOULD TACKLE THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE ON OUR BUILT AND NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. AND WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISS SMITH. WE'VE
CONCLUDED- YOUR LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY NINE
SO MOVE ON TO THE GALLERY ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO. TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY NINE
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING CHECK IT'S
ALSO MEMBERS CHRISLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FORTY NINE IN THE
GALLERY. OKAY SEE NONE A MISTER
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PROMPT THE
QUEUE FOR ANY ONE. ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY NINE PLEASE. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BY
IN SUPPORT FOR SB ONE ZERO FOUR
NINE. GOING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
FOR S. B. TEN FORTY NINE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AT ONE QUEUING UP
. ANYBODY ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL ALIGN TWENTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. MORNING AMANDA
WALDRON WITH TRIPLE A AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND FOR
ANYBODY ELSE QUITE IT ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR TEN FORTY NINE. NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WITH
INCLUDED- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FORTY NINE SOLD WILL
CONTINUE THE SAME PROCESS WITH
PROCESS IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
FORTY NINE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES- MARKED HERE SO
WE'LL GO ON TO THE GALLERY IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TEN FORTY NINE PLEASE. XENON MR
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
YOU FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
FORTY NINE PLEASE. THANK YOU TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO IN
FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THE ONE FILED
BY. ZERO M. MEDICARE NOBODY IS
KILLING US OKAY THANK YOU SO IT
CONCLUDED BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR RICK OWSKI-
MANAGER AT THE END OF A PAGE FOR
THE STAFF REPORT- SUGGESTS THAT
WE MAY WANT TO LOOK AT CRITERIA
FOR- CHOOSING THE ELIGIBLE
PROJECTS AND IN WHAT HOW WE
WOULD PRIORITIZE THAT WORKS I
KNOW IN OTHER DISCUSSIONS WE'RE
LOOKING AT NATURE BASED-
RESOLUTIONS THIS SORT OF TO GIVE
A PRIORITY. IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN
GENERAL WHERE WOULD YOU GO TO
THOSE NATURE BREEZE-
ALTERNATIVES- THERE'S NOT MUCH
IN THE BILL AS THE STAFF REPORT
PUTS OUT SO I WAS WONDERING IF
THE AUTHOR- ADVOCATES- CAN
CONTACT- COMMENT ON THAT. IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE QUESTION
ALSO RAISE VERSUS THE MONEY
COMING IN FOR STATE STREET'S
VERSUS LOCAL STREETS AND HELP
THAT. CONUNDRUM WILL BE
ADDRESSED OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
MCCASKEY SENATOR DODD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND YEAH IT JUST IT
AT LIKE ONE OF MY- EXPERTS TO-
TO OPINE ON THIS. I'D THAT THAT
WAS A SUGGESTION THAT WAS MADE
THE STAFF REPORT I JUST FELT
LIKE THAT MADE SENSE AND I THINK
THERE WAS. THERE WAS CERTAINLY
NO OPPOSITION TO DOING THAT
WOULD ULTIMATELY AT THE END. OF
HOPEFULLY RESULT IN A BETTER
PRODUCT BUT IF THEY'VE GOT
ANYTHING. MORE TO SAY UP ABOVE
I'D BE HAPPY HERE ABSOLUTELY I
BELIEVE THE- CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION WILL
ALSO BE A WEIGHING IN ON THIS AS
WELL THAT WILL KICK IT OFF TO
MISSOURI AND I JUST IF YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING ELSE. YEAH
SO THE WAY THAT THE BILL
STRUCTURE THE PRIORITIZATION AT
THIS POINT IS THAT- REQUIRES
THAT THE CTC AT. DIRECT
RESOURCES TO PROJECT RESOURCES
TO THE TRANSPORTATION NETWORKS
MOST HIGH PRIORITY VULNERABLE
ASSETS. AND IN MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION IT DIRECTS THE
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER. THE
DEGREE OF RISK FOR RECURRING
DAMAGE- ASSET FAILURE DUE TO
CLIMATE THREATS. ON IT
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIES THAT FOR
PROJECTS ON THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM THE COMMISSION SHALL
CONSULT THE DEPARTMENT REALLY
ROBUST ADAPTATION PRIORITIZATION
WORK. AND THERE'S ALREADY BEEN
UNDERTAKEN. AND THEN- SO THE
SECOND PRIORITIZATION COMPONENT
IS THAT. THEY CONSIDER THE
BENEFITS OF THE PROJECTS TO
PRESERVING OR ENHANCING REGIONAL
OR STATEWIDE MOBILITY ECONOMY
GOODS MOVEMENT SAFETY. AND OTHER
BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH
PROTECTING THE ASSETS. AND THEN
THIRDLY IT DIRECTS AT
PRIVATIZATION FOR PROJECTS THAT.
BENEFIT PURPOSE SORRY BENEFITS
OF THE PROJECT TO REDUCE
PRESERVING OR PROTECTING
ADJACENT COMMUNITIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AND OTHER CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO THAT'S THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TIER ONE
PRIORITIZATION. AND THEN YOU
KNOW IN ADDITION IT. REQUIRES
THE CDC TO GIVE EXTRA CREDIT IF
YOU WOULD TO AT PROJECTS THAT.
ALSO HELP ADVANCE OTHER STATE.
PRIORITIES AND STATE GOALS
INCLUDING REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS-
PROMOTING SYSTEM RESILIENCE AND
INCLUDING THE USE OF NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND HELPING TO
REDUCE CLIMATE RISKS FOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE
IN THE VICINITY OF THE PROJECT.
MAN CHARGED I WAS JUST THAT I
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR YOU
KNOW THE- THE LEGISLATURE HAS A
RICH HISTORY OF HUNTING
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE AIRPORT-
PUNTING RESPONSIBILITY THAT PVC
OR PUNTING RESPONSIBILITY THAT.
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO SORT OF
COME UP WITH THAT AND WE'VE BEEN
CRITICIZED OF NOT GIVING ANOTHER
DIRECTION AND- WE HAVE. WE HAVE
CLIMATE. GOALS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE THE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
AND THEN IF A PIECE OF THAT IS
THE HIGHWAY THAT THE ROADS AND
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
RIGHT HAND LEFT HAND TALKING
BECAUSE- SOME OF THOSE. I'M
SUGGESTING THAT SOMETIMES WE
MIGHT HAVE TO ABANDON THE ROADS
ARE RE ROUTE OR ROAD IN ORDER TO
GET A GREETER. CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PROJECT FOR SEA LEVEL
RISE- FOR FLOODING THAT THE
CALTRANS NCTC HAS SORT OF BEEN
OUT THERE. THAT'S OUR JOB IS TO
MAINTAIN THE ROADS YOU KNOW KEEP
THE ROADS OPEN SO JUST THIS IS
THIS IS AN INVITATION WITH THE
BILL TO DO. A DEEPER DIVE ON
THOSE THINGS AND THEN THEY MAKE
SURE THAT AT LEAST WE CREATE A
RECORD HERE THAT CTC AFTER
LISTENING THAT THIS IS NOT JUST.
YOU KNOW SHOULD BUILD. FOR YEARS
AND EVERY ROSE TO THE FLAME
DOESN'T MAKE IT SOMETIMES IT MAY
MEETING AND AN ALTERNATIVE
DESIGN THAT'S A MUCH BIGGER.
BENEFIT FOR THE COMMUNITY AT
LARGE FOR- FLOODING OR WHATEVER
IT MAY BE ABSOLUTELY CENTER BY
CAL SKI AND- AGREED AND WE TALK
TO THE AUTHOR ABOUT THAT I KNOW
HE HE UNDERSTANDS THAT THE
CRITERIA FOR PRIORITIZATION IS
IMPORTANT. WE'RE LUCKY TO ALSO
HAVE ONE OF OUR CTC
COMMISSIONERS HERE IN THE SENATE
A SENATOR NEWMAN SO WE CAN START
LOBBYING HIM TOMORROW. MANY OF
THESE. ITEMS ALL ALL JOKING
ASIDE I KNOW THAT- SENATOR DODD
ALONG WITH HIS LEAD WITNESSES
ARE ARE DEFINITELY- GOING TO BE
ON TOP OF THIS THIS ISSUE
ABSOLUTELY AND WE SHOULD. WEIGH
IN AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT. I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER MAKES UP A SENATOR
DOT WOULD YOU LIKE AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AT THE SPECS WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AT THIS TIME AS P. TEN
NINETEEN FORTY NINE TO HAVE A
MOTION. ON AS BETWEEN TEN FORTY
NINE SENATOR NEWMAN. OKAY THANK
YOU SOME OF BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
AND MR CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON SP TEN
FOR NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CENTERS GONZALEZ
HI. THE DOLLARS I BET. HI EIGHT
HI ELLEN. SUCH A LETTER.
ARCHULETA HI BECKER. PATES
CORTESE I. DALI DOLLY I THOUGHT
. HI MOM. WHERE MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S I MEANT. NEWMAN NEWMAN
I RUBIO. RUBIO HIGH SKINNER. HI
WHITE HOUSE K. BY KELSEY I WILL
. SENTIMENT MAN I. WELL OKAY
TWELVE VOTES- SO LOOKS LIKE IT
HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT WILL
ENSURE THAT ITS ON CALL THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD AND YOU HAVE
YOUR NEXT BILL UP WHICH IS S. B.
TEN FIFTY PLEASE PRESENT THANK
YOU THANKS AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- SP TEN FIFTY WOULD
AUTHORIZE TOLLING ON STATE ROUTE
THIRTY SEVEN GOVERNED BY THE BAY
AREA INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
AUTHORITY. EVA IS THE ACRONYM
THIS IS A CRITICAL STEP TOWARD
PROVIDING THE NECESSARY REVENUE
TO IMPROVE RESILIENCY THIS VITAL
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
FROM SEA LEVEL RISE AND FLOODING
WHILE ALSO DEALING WITH
CONGESTION ENVIRONMENTAL HANDS
ENHANCEMENTS TRANSIT IN ACTIVE
OTHER ACTIVE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION. IT'S THE MAJOR
CORRIDOR EXTENDING FROM U. S.
ONE OH ONE THE MOTTO THE
INTERSTATE EIGHTY IN VALLEJO IT
IS HERS VITAL CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN THE COUNTIES OF MARIN
NAPA SONOMA AND SOLANO IN MY
DISTRICT. YES SIR THIRTY SEVEN
IS UNIQUE CORRIDOR WITH LONG
STRETCHES OF LOW LYING ROAD
SURROUNDED BY ECOLOGICALLY RICH
WETLANDS. AT THE EDGE OF THE SAN
PABLO BAY NATIONAL WILDLIFE
REFUGE MAKING IT PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO FLOODING AND SEA
LEVEL RISE. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE ROAD FLOODED FOR
OVER A MONTH. IN OVER A WEEK IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. IT HAS
SOME OF THE WORST CONGESTION IN
THE REGION IMPACTING COMMUTERS
VISITORS IN FREIGHT MOVEMENT
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK IT HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY CALTRANS IS ONE OF
OUR MOST AT RISK. TRANSPORTATION
ASSETS. RECENT REPORTS BY
CALTRANS- ALSO NOTED THAT IT
COULD BE PERMANENTLY INUNDATED
AS SOON AS TWENTY FORTY.
ESTABLISHING A TOLL ROAD
AUTHORITY IS CRITICALLY CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO PROVIDE PART OF THE
REVENUE NEEDED TO SUSTAIN THIS
IMPORTANT TRANSPORTATION ARTERY
. THE BILL SPECIFIES A TOLL
REVENUE WILL INCLUDE AN INTERIM
IN OLDHAM IT PROJECTS AS WELL AS
ECOLOGICAL RESTORATION AND
ADAPTIVE IMPROVEMENTS. MEMBERS
THIS IS A MASSIVE PROJECT HE HAD
A VERY EXPENSIVE ONE AT THAT HE
WILL TAKE MULTIPLE FUNDING
SOURCES TO COMPLETE. WHAT TOLLS
ALONE CANNOT MEET THE NEEDS OF
THIS PROJECT THEY ARE A VITAL
SOURCE OF LOCAL MATCHING FUNDS
THAT WILL INCREASE THE PROJECT'S
COMPETITIVENESS FOR ADDITIONAL
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS. LASTLY
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CHEERS CONCERNS ABOUT EQUITY IN
THE IMPACTS OF TOLLS ON LOW
INCOME DRIVERS I SHARE THESE
CONCERNS AFTER ALL THESE ARE MY
CONSTITUENTS. THAT WILL BE USING
THE ROAD MORE THAN EVERYONE ELSE
AND THAT'S WHY I INCLUDED
PROVISIONS FOR DISCOUNTS FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS IN THE FORCE
SURROUNDING COUNTIES. MOREOVER
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD I WILL
BE ADDING LANGUAGE TO EXTEND THE
DISCOUNT THE EIGHTY LOW INCOME
DRIVER WITH A FAST TRACK. TO
FURTHER ADDRESS THIS CONCERN. I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. THEY ARE
REBECCA LONG ON BEHALF OF THE
BEST BALL TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND SUZANNE SMITH
FROM THE CINEMA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD WILL START WITH
RESPECT ALONG WITH MTC THANK YOU
AND WELCOME. GOOD MORNING TERROR
GONZALEZ BY SURVEYS AND MEMBERS
MY NAME'S ROCK ALONG AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION AND
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AT MTC. SP TEN
FIFTY WILL HELP GENERATE FUNDS
FOR A MOBILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT ON A HIGHLY CONGESTED
STRETCH OF STATE ROAD THIRTY
SEVEN BETWEEN VALLEJO AND SEARS
POINT THAT CONSISTS OF A SINGLE
LANE IN EACH DIRECTION AND CAN
TAKE DRIVERS MORE THAN AN HOUR
AND A HALF TO TRAVEL WHICH
SHOULD TAKE A LITTLE OVER TWENTY
MINUTES HOME FROM WORK. THIS
DELAY IMPOSES A MAJOR COST ON
CURRENT MOTORISTS IN THE FORM OF
WASTED TIME AND FUEL WHILE STUCK
IN TRAFFIC. BY ADDING TOOLS TO
THE CORRIDOR THE PROJECT NOT
ONLY HELPS TO GENERATE MATCHING
FUNDS FOR THIS MOBILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT. IT ALSO
HELPS TO LIMIT THE GROWTH IN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE RESULT FROM
ADDING JUST A REGULAR GENERAL
PURPOSE LANES. AT THE SAME TIME
BYOFFERING A 50% TOLL DISCOUNT
TO CARPOOLS ALONG WITH A WITH A
RELIABLE TRANSIT OPTION THE
PROJECT WILL ENABLE MORE PEOPLE
PER HOUR TO TRAVEL THROUGH THE
CORRIDOR. THE BILL ALSO BREAKS
NEW POLICY GROUNDS AS SENATOR
DODGES SHARED REQUIRING A TOLL
DISCOUNT FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS TO HELP OFFSET THE
DISPERSION DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT OF THE TOLLS. AS NOTED BY
SENATOR DODD ANOTHER URGENT GOAL
OF SP TEN FIFTY EAST RIVER
PROVIDE MATCHING FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE QUARTERS LONG TERM
RESILIENCE. IN THE FACE OF SEA
LEVEL RISE WHICH THREATENS THE
ROADWAY WITHIN THE NEXT EIGHTEEN
TO THIRTY YEARS. WELL THE
MOBILITY PROJECT IS ON TRACK TO
BEGIN CONSTRUCTION IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THE ALTERNATE
PROJECT WILL TAKE LONGER TO
DESIGN CONDUCT ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
ANNOUNCED THE FUNDS FOR PROJECTS
WITH AN ESTIMATED COST OF OVER
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. WITH S. B.
TEN FIFTY A PORTION OF THE TOLL
FUNDS WILL BE AVAILABLE TO BEGIN
THAT WORK. SO THAT THE ULTIMATE
PROJECT CAN GAIN CRITICAL
MOMENTUM. NOW IS A UNIQUE MOMENT
IN THE FEDERAL FUNDING LANDSCAPE
WHERE CONGRESS HAS RECENTLY
PROVIDED FUNDS TRANSPORTATION
RESILIENCE. SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
WILL BE COMPETITIVE GRANTS
SELECTED BY USDOT. STATE ROUTE
THIRTY SEVEN WILL FACE SOME
STIFF OMPETITION AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AND ONE OF THE
BEST WAYS TO COMPETE IS BY
DEMONSTRATING THAT YOU HAVE SKIN
IN THE GAME. AND BY THAT I MEAN
MATCHING FUNDS. IN SUMMARY S. B.
TEN FIFTY WILL HELP FUND NEAR
TERM MOBILITY IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WILL FACILITATE TRANSIT AND
CARPOOLING ON A ROADWAY WHERE
NONE OF THIS IS A VIABLE OPTION
TODAY. ALONG WITH THE LONG TERM
RESILIENCE OF ONE OF THE BAY
AREA'S VITAL EAST WEST COMMUTE
AND GOODS MOVEMENT CORRIDORS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
LONG NEXT MOVE ON TO SUZANNE
SMITH WITH A C. T. EIGHT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SUZANNE SMITH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CINEMA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION OF
AUTHORITY- WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN FIFTY THERE IS NO TIME TO
WASTE WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS AT RISK
FROM CLIMATE CHANGE. HIGHWAY
THIRTY SEVEN IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA IS THE POSTER CHILD PROJECT
WHEN IT COMES TO A CRITICAL
COURT OR- IN IMMINENT PERIL FROM
SEA LEVEL RISE. GIVEN OUR
TOPOGRAPHY WE ARE VERY LIMITED
OPTIONS FOR EAST WEST
CONNECTIVITY IN THE NORTH BAY
AND HIGHWAY THIRTY SEVEN IS THE
KILLING FOR THE MOVEMENT OF
PEOPLE AND GOODS. PLUS IT SERVES
AS AN IT HAS SERVED AS AN
EVACUATION ROUTE DURING
WILDFIRES. AND AS AN ALTERNATIVE
ROUTE WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS TO
THE RICHMOND SAN RAFAEL BRIDGE
WITHOUT HIGHWAY THIRTY SEVEN
WERE FRANKLY IN BIG TROUBLE.
RIGHT NOW EVEN WITH PANDEMIC
TRAFFIC LEVELS THE DELAY FOR
COMMUTERS IS NINETY MINUTES WHAT
SHOULD BE A FORTY MINUTE ROUND
TRIP FROM INDIA AND IS NOW IN
EXCESS OF TWO HOURS. THAT IS AN
IMPACT TO PEOPLE'S LIVES EVERY
DAY AS WELL AS THEIR WELL BEING
NOT TO MENTION THE COST OF AN
IDLING VEHICLE WITH TODAY'S FUEL
PRICES. S. B. TEN FIFTY WILL
HELP US DELIVER IMPROVEMENTS
QUICKLY BY PROVIDING A LOCAL
MATCH TO STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDS. AND ENSURING THE CORRIDOR
WILL HAVE ONGOING FUNDS TO
SUPPORT TRANSIT AND DEVELOPING
THE ULTIMATE RESILIENCE PROJECT
THAT WILL GET THE COURT ARE OUT
OF HARM'S WAY. WHILE ALSO
RESTORING CRITICAL WETLANDS AND
HABITAT. PRICE IN THE CORRIDOR
HAS HIS ROOTS THE ORIGINAL
HIGHWAY WAS A TOLL ROAD. PLUS IT
IS IN KEEPING WITH STATE
REQUIREMENTS TO REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AND PROVIDE
TRANSIT OPTIONS. WE NEED THOSE
CARPOOL LANES AND TRANSIT
OPTIONS A. S. A. P. WE NEED TO
LOOK AT DOING PROJECTS
DIFFERENTLY MEGA PROJECTS LIKE
THIS MUST HAVEAS MANY TOOLS AS
POSSIBLE TO ENSURE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE DELIVERY. IT AT THE
SAME TIME WE RECOGNIZE THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS ALSO HAPPEN IN
PHASES. THAT'S OUR APPROACH AT
S. B. TEN FIFTY IS A VITAL PIECE
OF THE STRATEGY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH- SO IF
CONCLUDED LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY STILL
MOVE ON TO THE GALLERY ANY
OTHER. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
YES. PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR DARYL HALL'S SECOND DRUG
TO THE SLAUGHTER TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY ONE OF THE PARTNERS IN
ACCOUNTING AND PC. WHERE TO
CONVEY OUR SUPPORT WE PROVIDE
YOU WITH A SUPPORT LETTER. URGED
ME TO ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU TO SENATOR DODD FOR
HIS AUTHORSHIP. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TEN FIFTY IN THE
GALLERY. RIGHT C. NINE MISTER
MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO YOU TO
THE A TELECONFERENCE LINE LOOK
FOR ANY OTHER WITNESSES WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FIFTY. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
TEXT PRESS FOR S. B. TEN FIFTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY FIVE ANYBODY ELSE GOING
AT ONE ZERO TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR TEN FIFTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWENTY FIVE. HI GOOD MORNING
FIFTY BLOCK ON THE ON THE NAPA
VALLEY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
ALSO OR THE PARTNER TO MEASURE
ENERGY OR SUPPORT THANKS. AND WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NOBODY ELSE
GOING AT ONE ZERO. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR SB. ONE ZERO FIVE
FIVE ZERO. IN LINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR OPEN HELLO MY NAME'S KATIE
MURRAY I'M WITH THE NORTH BAY
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL REPRESENTING
THE LEADING EMPLOYERS IN MARIN
SONOMA AND NAPA COUNTIES WE COOK
WITH COLLECTIVELY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER WITH MULTIPLE
REASONS BUT WE WANT YOU TO
PLEASE UNDERSTAND. THAT THIS
HIGHWAY IS CRITICAL TO THE NORTH
BAY CONNIE WELL BEING AND PUBLIC
SAFETY THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS MARK FROM THE COSMETOLOGY
BETTER STREETS IN ORANGE COUNTY
I WISH WE COULD HAVE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS IN COSTA MESA STREET
ROUTE FIFTY FIVE AND I ENCOURAGE
SUPPORT OF THIS AS A PRECEDENT
FOR OTHER. PLACES THANK YOU. THE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB. ONE
ZERO FIVE ZERO. YEAH MAN I'M
SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WITH SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FIFTY WILL MOVE ON
WITH THE SAME PROCESS FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OF
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSE TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN FIFTY
PLEASE. THE C. NINE MISTER
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
YOU FOR ANY WITNESSES IN THE
QUEUE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN FIFTY.
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO THE SP TEN FIFTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NO PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP. OKAY THANK YOU HAVE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WILL TAKE IT BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. OKAY SEE NONE AND
SENATOR DODD I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH- THE COMMITTEE I KNOW I
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT
THE EQUITY COMPONENT- AT THIS
TIME THE CAP THE CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT ROAD PRICING AT THIS
TIME SO. I WILL STAY OFF OF THE
BILL AT THIS MOMENT BUT I KNOW
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THIS AND I THINK M. T. C. AS
WELL AND THE PARTNERS IN
TRANSPORTATION IN SINNOH MONOMER
AND- HAVE CONTINUED TO WORK WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS AS WELL. SO
WITH THAT- I WILL ENGAGE IN
MOTION ON SP TEN FIFTY FROM
SENATORS. THIS TIME SENATOR
TWELVE THANK YOU. AND MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON SP TEN FIFTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. CENTERS
IN THE US. NO BASE NOW ALAN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI BECKER
CORTESE CORTESE II DOLLY DOLLY
NO DOT HI DON HI THE MOST. WHERE
BELINDA'S BELINDA SNELL MEN.
NEWMAN NEWMAN I YEP RUBIO II
SCANNER. BY CAL SKI. WELCOME.
FIVE OKAY WE HAVE FIVE GUYS AT
THIS POINT BELIEVE IT ON CALL
FOR YOU AS SENATOR DODD THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU AS WELL AND NOW I'M GONNA
HAND THE GAVEL OFF TO OUR DEAR
VICE CHAIR SENATOR BATES WHO
WILL TAKE OVER WHILE I PRESENT
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR FORTUNE
TINO.
THERE.
ARE YOU PREPARED SANITARY
CONDOLENCE YES THEY WILL SEE
THEM MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY AND PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR PORTENT TINO ON S. C.
TEN SEVENTY NINE SENATOR PORTMAN
TINO HAS AGREED TO THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE BILL
AND HAS ALSO PUT FORTH AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS WHICH CAN BE FOUND IN
COMMON TEN WHICH ADDRESS SOME
EQUITY IN PRIVACY CONCERNS IT IS
CURRENTLY ILLEGAL TO MODIFY A
VEHICLE AND ANYWAY THAT
AMPLIFIES THE NOISE EMITTED BY
THE VEHICLE ADDITIONALLY FOR THE
AVERAGE CAR SIZE THEY CANNOT
EMIT SOUNDS GREATER THAN NINETY
FIVE DECIBELS THERE IS CURRENTLY
NO UNIVERSAL MEANS TO MONITOR
AND ENFORCE THESE LAWS EXPOSURE
TO LOUD SOUNDS INCLUDING NOISE
FROM VEHICLE EXHAUST SYSTEMS.
CAN HARM OUR HEALTH AND WELL
BEING BY CONTRIBUTING TO
HYPERTENSION HEARING LOSS
SLEEPING DIFFICULTIES INCREASE
STRESS LEVELS CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE PSYCHIATRIC DISORDERS
AND CHILD DEVELOPMENT ISSUES
ADDITIONALLY LOUD VEHICLE
EXHAUST ALSO PUTS PEDESTRIANS
AND CYCLISTS AT RISK WHILE
THEY'RE ON THE ROAD AND OFTEN
TIMES AS LOUD NOISE A VEHICLE
NOISES ACCOMPANIED BY OTHER
RECKLESS BEHAVIORS SUCH AS
STREET RACING AND SIDESHOWS
WHICH FURTHER ENDANGER LIVES AS
THE TEN SEVENTY NINE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE DISCUSSED
TODAY WILL CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM ALLOWING A LIMITED
NUMBER OF CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT AUTOMATED NOISE CAMERA
PROGRAMS. TO DETECT ILLEGALLY
LOUD VEHICLE EXHAUST AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL EQUITY IN PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR A VOTE ON SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALO
ON THE PRIMARIES WITNESSES ARE
ON NOW THE TELECONFERENCING LINE
ABOVE THE FISH WAS STREETS FOR
ALL. IN MAYOR PRO TEM MIKE POSEY
WITH THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH. MR MODERATOR WE OPEN THE
LINES FOR OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES.
AND HAVE THEM IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES. I DECIDED TO BUY THE
BEST FROM CONTROL. YES MY COZY.
THEN BEGAN. BUT WITH FISH GOOD
MORNING- GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MIKE POSEY AND THE MAYOR PRO
TEM OF THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH. ON BEHALF OF OUR CITIES
IN OUR GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE. ALL CITY COUNCIL
BE. TAKING A POSITION AT A
COUNCIL MEETING ON APRIL THE
FIFTH. THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH IS A COASTAL COMMUNITY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COMPOSED OF
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
RESIDENTS. I'VE BEEN A RESIDENT
HOMEOWNER CITY HUNTINGTON BEACH
FOR THE PAST TWENTY THREE YEARS
AND I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND THE
IMPACT OF LARGE VEHICLE NOISE ON
OUR COMMUNITY. WHAT VEHICLE
NOISE IS A PERSISTENT PROBLEM IN
OUR COMMUNITY BOTH ILLEGALLY
MODIFIED CARS AS WELL AS BRAND
NEW SUPERCARS AND MODIFIED
MOTORCYCLES ROAM THE STREETS OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH. A PACIFIC
COAST HIGHWAY AND CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT QUALITY OF LIFE
CONCERNS FOR THE RESIDENTS OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH. JEANNE ALLOWED
VEHICLE NOISE POLLUTION CAN
DISRUPT THE DAILY LIVES OF
RESIDENTS AND EVEN LONG TERM
EFFECTS ON MENTAL HEALTH. AS
WELL AS SERIOUS IMPACTS
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE AREAS
SUCH AS THE BOLSA CHICA
WETLANDS. AND A CITY ON THE
BEACH HERE IN HUNTINGTON BEACH.
CITY COUNCIL RECEIVED NUMEROUS
COMPLAINTS FROM RESIDENTS
WEEKLY. THESE VEHICLES ARE HARD
TO CATCH IN THE ACT AND WE
BELIEVE SP TEN SOMETHING AND
WILL BRING SOME ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT MEASURES. TO
EXISTING LAW. FOUND ACTIVATING
ENFORCEMENT DEVICES ARE ALREADY
BEING USED IN OTHER STATES AND
OVERSEAS WITH GREAT RESULTS.
THREE HUNTINGTON BEACH SEVEN
REGIONAL LEADER IN ADDRESSING
LOG VEHICLE NOISE RIGHT HERE IN
THE COUNTY ALONG WITH OURS
NEIGHBORING CITIES IN LAGUNA
BEACH SEAL BEACH AND NEWPORT
BEACH WHOSE JOINTLY SET UP TASK
FORCES TO MAJOR MAJOR COMBINED
OPERATIONS INCLUDE EDUCATIONAL
CAMPAIGNS AND MESSAGE BOARDS. WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL AUTHORIZATION TO
ENFORCE BUT PEOPLE ALWAYS WILL
BE A HUGE HELP TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITY. AND IN BEHALF OF THE
SERIES INTERGOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS COMMITTEE WE ARE
EXCITED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
WITH THE INTENTION OF
IMPLEMENTING THE TECHNOLOGY IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF SP TEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU MARY TEM YOUR
CHECKING. THE NEXT WE HAVE THE
OTHER FISH. THESTREETS WERE ALL
. YEAH THANK YOU BALLOTS FOR
PRESERVING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE FOR
THE CHANCE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF IT TODAY BANKAMERICA BEFORE-
YOUR TESTIMONY AS WELL MANY OF
THE FISHER LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
AT THREE TWELVE IN LA COUNTY
NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO ST
EQUITABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION AND WE ARE PROUD
SPONSOR AT THE SEVENTY NINE
WOULD LIKE ASK YOUR SUPPORT- AS
NEAR POSEY- TOUCHED ON WITH
POLLUTION IS NOT MERELY A
NUISANCE IT'S A GROWING PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE IN OUR CITY. LARGE
SCALE STUDIES SHOW THAT NOISE
EXPOSURE OVER MANY YEARS
INCREASE YOUR RISK OF HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE CORONARY HEART DISEASE
HEART ATTACK STROKE DIABETES
DEMENTIA AND DEPRESSION-
CHILDREN SUFFER NOT ONLY
PHYSICALLY BUT BEHAVIOR BILLY
AND COGNITIVELY- I'M IN N. ONE
THIRTY- A GROUP OF FIFTH
GRADERS- WITH MOORED NEARBY
URBAN VILLAGE LAD NEARLY A YEAR
BEHIND THOSE STUDENTS REQUIRE
CLASSROOM A DIFFERENT THAT WAS
MADE UP. ONE THEIR CLASSROOMS
DOWN PRETTY SO I'M SPEAKING FROM
EXPERIENCE AS WELL I LIVE IN
WASHINGTON BOULEVARD ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BUSIEST CORRIDORS IN
CULVER CITY ANY LEGAL ILLEGALLY
MODIFIED MUFFLERS TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY ON A DAILY BASIS AND
THE PROBLEM IS ONLY EXACERBATED
THAT THESE MUFFLERS UPSTAIRS IN
POPULARITY NOISE LEVELS PRODUCED
BY THEM ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL BUT
THE PATTERN FOR CEMENT- MAKES
THE PROBLEM PERSISTS. TELL THE
IMPORTANT BILLABLE OUT THE NEED
TO IMPORT A LOT WITHOUT ARMS
POLICE ENFORCEMENT- EIGHT NOT IN
THE KNOW THE PARKING PROGRAM
THAT WAS MODELED ON THOSE
ALREADY IN PLACE IN PARIS
NASHVILLE IN NEW YORK CITY ANY
DEVICES MUST BE SOUND ACTIVATED
MEANING THERE ONLY TO CAPTURE AN
IMAGE WHEN IN YOU LEGALLY
ALLOWED MUFFLERS FOUND IT ACTED.
WE WILL HAVE MORE TO INCLUDE A
MULTITUDE OF OTHER PROVISIONS TO
PROTECT PRIVATE INSURER THE USED
TO BE DIVIDED INTO THIRTY FIVE
OR DISTRIBUTED IN A WAY THAT
HELPS NOT HARMS THE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES OFTEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IMPACTED BY
STREET RACING. ISN'T INCLUDE
REQUIRE THAT ALL AN IMAGE THE
LIGHT PLATE OF THE VEHICLE BE
CASH. A WARNING FOR TIME.
FORGIVENESS PRO FOR LOW IN
VEHICLE. AND PROVISION MANDATING
DATA BE DESTROYED UPON THE REST
OF THE- IT ALSO WORTH NOTING THE
REVENUE OF THE PRO. YOUR THE FOR
CASH COMING. MAKERS THINKING
PAPER THIS IS ALSO A TO TRANSFER
DEPARTMENT NOT LONG BEFORE.
SIMILAR TO PARKING TO MANY
JURISDICTIONS. AT THREE TEN
SEVENTY NINE WILL CREATE A
PILOT. THAT ENABLE TO COLLECT.
DATA THAT WILL HELP IMPROVE
PROGRAM OVER TIME. I URGE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND HELP IT
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS OUR
SHARED GOAL. OF CREATING
PEACEFUL HEALTHY URBAN
ENVIRONMENT FOR EVERYONE. THANKS
SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ON THE SURFACE- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES HERE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY. ANYONE WISHING TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY I DON'T SEE
ANY THEN- GO TO ARM OUR
MODERATOR. AND ASK HIM TO OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. MR
MODERATOR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
. THANK YOU- IT JUST EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR SB TEN SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN PRESS ONE ZERO TO.
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE AND WE WILL BEGIN
TO FIND THIRTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN
. MICHAEL SNYDER PROMOTES
ANGELUS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BATTLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS MARK
WITH THE BENCH FROM THE COSTA
MESA LINE THROUGH BETTER STREETS
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL. AND NEXT IN LINE
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOSHUA
COOPER I'M A RESIDENT OF NORTH
HOLLYWOOD AND AS A NEW PARENT
ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT NOISE POLLUTION
I SUPPORT THAT BECAUSE THEN THE
NINE. THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR SP TEN SEVENTY NINE POINT
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU COULD YOU REMEMBER
CIRCLED ON ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LAGUNA BEACH AND SUPPORT. AND
MEDICARE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU THEN WE HAVE COMPLETED ALL
OF THE SUPPORT WITNESSES WILL
NOW GO TO THOSE WHO MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION- I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY COMING FORWARD.
IN MR MODERATOR COULD YOU GO TO
THE PHONES LINES AND SEE IF WE
HAVE ANYONE QUEUED UP TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. TEN SEVENTY
NINE. EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE. AND WE WILL ALIGN
TWENTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
ACCERN NUMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ
WITH CORBIN AND TIGER ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION I APOLOGIZE-
OPPOSITION CAME IN A LITTLE
LATE- YOU'RE STILL THE PROCESS
OF REVIEWING BILLS AND STILL MY
CONCERN WILL BE QUICKLY
ADDRESSED IN REGARDS TO THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL AND
FRAN- WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE
TEXT OF THE BILL THAT THE DEBATE
ABOUT WHAT TECHNOLOGY EVEN.
BETTER TO BE AUTHORIZED- THERE'S
NO DEFINITION OF AN ACTIVATED
IMPORTANT DIVIDE THE PUBLIC
SHOULD BE FULLY INFORMED ABOUT
WHAT THE TECHNOLOGY YOU WHAT
DATA THEY COLLECT AND WHO HAS
ACCESS TO THAT DATA I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. INTERVAL PROGRESSES
THANK YOU. FIND FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUR STANDARD ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION WITH
CONCERNS ABOUT IT TO BE TEN
SEVENTY NINE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DOCTOR ABOUT ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES TO NOISE POLLUTION
THAT DO NOT INCREASE
SURVEILLANCE OF TICKETING RELY
ON AUTOMATED ENFORCEMENT. THANK
YOU. M. AND THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE IN LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU THIS IS-
TRACY CLINTON BURKE CALLING FROM
OAKLAND TO PRIVATELY AND WE'RE
CALLING IN CURRENT OPPOSITION TO
THEM FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU. AND THEN I'M SURE
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP. THANK YOU THERE NO
OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES
THAT'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
FINISHER ARCHULETA- I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR I WOULD-LIKE TO JUST POINT OUT THAT-
OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL ADDRESSES
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT SO MANY
OF OUR MUNICIPALITIES THAT WE
ALL REPRESENT. CITY UPON CITY
UPON CITY- IN CALIFORNIA A
REPORTING BACK TO ALL OF US
THAT- SOME OF THE PEOPLE WITH
THE DRIVE IN THE CENTER SECTION
ROUND AND ROUND AND ROUND.
CAUSING PROBLEMS BECAUSE THE
NOISE- THIS IS A WAY THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN WORK WITH THE
CITY'S WORK WITH THE COMMUNITIES
AND DO IT FAIRLY AND EQUITABLY
BECAUSE IT'S A SOUND TECHNOLOGY
THAT IS DETERMINING IF SOMEONE
HAS VIOLATED THE LAW. NOT AN
OFFICER HIMSELF OR HERSELF YOU
TERMINATE IF YOU VIOLATE THE LAW
IT IS THE TECHNOLOGY THERE IS
THE FAIRNESS THERE IS EQUALITY
AND CONSEQUENTLY IT ADDRESSES
THE ISSUES THAT SOME OF THE
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE TODAY. SO I
STRONGLY URGE AND I VOTE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AND
ASKED TO BE A CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU. YOU HAVE A MOTION ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM.
COMMITTEE BOTH ARE UNDETERMINED
. THANK YOU I WANT TO ADD A
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A NUMBER
OF THE COASTAL COMMUNITIES
MENTIONED INCLUDING HUNTING
INVASION PORT BEACH AND LAGUNA
BEACH- I KNOW THAT THIS IS A
VEXING AND GROWING PROBLEM THAT
AS OUR WITNESSES THAT TESTIFIED
ARTICULATELY- TOO EASY SOMETHING
THAT. IMPACT QUALITY OF LIFE IT
HAS DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS ON THE
WILDLIFE SANCTUARIES THAT BORDER
A LOT OF THESE. AREAS ON THE P.
C. H. I. AND IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT PROBLEM TO TRY TO
ENFORCE AGAINST SO- I SUPPORT
THIS BILL- I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AT THE-
APPROPRIATE TIME. AND- WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. YOU DO HAVE A
MOTION- FINISH MY COFFEE. BUT SO
I AM. I WOULD SAY I THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION IS
DECISION ON THE PRIVACY CONCERNS
AND HOW THIS INFORMATION IS
GOING TO BE. USED FOR LEGITIMATE
WITH THAT SAID I LIKE THE
MOVEMENT OF THIS BILL GOING INTO
A PILOT PROGRAM. VERSES AS IT
WAS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED I
GUESS THE QUESTION FOR THE
CHAIR- IS. YOU KNOW IS THIS. IS
THIS IS SIMPLE- FIX A TICKET
THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET. OR
DO WE WANT BASIS GONNA BE USED
AS A YU KNOW A FRACTION THAT-
OR THAT GOES ONTO THE COUNTS
AGAINST THEIR INSURANCE. ON THAT
AND DIDN'T. THE NOISE
VIOLATIONS. THE GOOD QUESTION
SENATOR GONZALEZ DID YOU HEAR
THAT SENATORS QUESTION I DID
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR MCCASKEY AT
THIS TIME WHAT WE'VE- ADDRESSING
THE AMENDMENT. IS THE FIRST
PENALTY. BASICALLY COULD BE. A
WAVE TO- AN IT IS THIS IS THIS
CLARIFIES THAT THE FOR NOTICE OF
VIOLATION WILL CARRY NO PENALTY
AND WHEN WILL INSTEAD BE
UNNOTICED WHICH PERMITS AN
OFFENDER TO REMEDY THE ISSUE ANY
SUBSEQUENT WILL BE A- AN
ADMINISTRATIVE VIOLATION IF THAT
CITY DOES HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION HOWEVER IF THEY
DON'T HAVE A DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION- IT WOULD DIFFER.
MOSTLY TO THE FOLKS THAT ARE
WITHIN THAT CITY THAT-
ADMINISTER TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS
WHICH COULD BE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND AT THAT POINT IT COULD BE
AT- A CITATION WITH THAT WITHIN
THAT DEPARTMENT SO THAT SHOULD
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE CLEARER- ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR'S WELL.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS YEAH.
YOU'RE NOT SENATOR DODD YOU'RE
JUST STRETCHING I THINK. HE YEAH
OKAY AND I DON'T SEE ANY ARE I
AM I'M GOING TO LAY OFF ON THE
BILL TODAY I KNOW AND IT IS A
MAJOR PROBLEM AND I REPRESENT
MANY COASTAL CITIES AND
CERTAINLY ON THE FREEWAY THAT
RUNS ALONG IT'S ACTUALLY P. C.
H. BUT I THINK THERE'S A FEW
MORE QUESTIONS THAT I NEED
ANSWERED BEFORE- I CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE SO I WILL LAY OFF
TODAY BUT TOMORROW WE DO HAVE A
MOTION OH. OH I'M SORRY IF A
LENDER FINANCE HIGHLANDER I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE TO THE
PROBLEM- PUTTING MY MAKE UP- I
DO HAVE A QUESTION IS SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS ABLE TO ANSWER IT I
KNOW IT IS NOT YOUR BILL BUT-
WHAT I HAVE BEEN HERE IS THAT. I
IT. IT'S C. REQUIRES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM TO CONSIDER A PERSON'S
ABILITY TO PAY THE PENALTY AND
ALLOW PAYMENT OF THE PENALTY IN
INSTALLMENTS OR DEFERRED PAYMENT
METHOD PERSON PROVIDES EVIDENCE
THAT THEIR- AND UNABLE TO PAY IT
IN FULL SO- I GUESS. IF THEY'RE
NOT ABLE. TO PAY THE FINE- I'M
JUST NOT SURE HOW THAT WORKS IS
YOU KNOW I MEAN IS THAT WHERE'S
THE ENFORCEMENT PART ARE WORSE
THAN. DEFERRING ARTISTIC IF YOU
CAN ANSWER. SURE I'LL TRY MY
BEST BUT- AGAIN I'LL JUST
REITERATE- ON THE FIRST
VIOLATION REGARDLESS OF ABILITY
TO PAY OR NOT THE FIRST
VIOLATION WOULD JUST BE WOULD BE
WAIVED AS ALMOST LIKE A WARNING
TO THAT THAT THE DRIVER THAT
THIS OCCURRED. I WILL CARRY OUT
THIS WITH THIS IS PRETTY NEW
TECHNOLOGY SO- IF THERE RE SORT
OF DISCREPANCIES BECAUSE THIS IS
IN THE FIRST GENERATION OF
TECHNOLOGY THEN THAT WOULD ALLOW
SOME SORT OF- REPRIEVE FOR THAT
VIOLATION BUT THE SUBSEQUENT
THAT WOULD BE A DIFF ANOTHER
QUESTION WE HAVE TO DIG INTO IN
TERMS OF. HOW THE JURISDICTION
IS WILLING TO WAIT EVEN TO WHAT
POINT- AND SO. WHO WHAT
QUALIFIES AS LOW INCOME A LOT OF
THOSE QUESTIONS THAT WOULD NEED
TO BE ANSWERED SO I WILL. WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR ENSURING THAT WE
GET THAT THOSE ARE SOLIDIFIED.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT I
JUST THIS IS REMINISCENT OF-
ISSUES THAT WE'VE HAD WITH RED
LIGHT CAMERAS IN CITIES BEING
SUED OVER THE USE OF THOSE. WITH
YOU KNOW PROBLEMS WITH THE
CALIBRATION AND THEM WORKING
PROPERLY AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE SAID THIS IS A BIT
CONCERNING GIVEN THAT IT IS- A
NEW TECHNOLOGY BUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR US. ADDRESSING THE
QUESTIONS THANK MENTOR THANK YOU
. AND I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
HANDS UP AND SENATOR GONZALEZ
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I VOTE
THANK YOU ON S. B. FIVE TEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. MR CONSULTANT YOU WANT TO
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. ON SP TEN
SEVENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATORS GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
BASE. ALAN ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
HI BECKER BECKER HIGH CORTESE
CORTESE II DOLLY. DOT. DONNA HI
THE MON. REQUIRE THE CHOIR I
WILL END THIS BELINDA SNELL. MID. MAN MAN MAN I. NEWMAN NEWMAN I
RUBIO RUBIO I IN A- SCANNER HI
BY KELSEY. WHY CASKEY I BOOK.
ELEVEN OKAY ELEVEN ONE THIS
LOOKS LIKE IT HAS ENOUGH TO GET
OUT AND WE WILL LEAVE ABOUT
PHONE CALL FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR FOR TAKING OVER
ON THAT BUILT UP NEXT WE WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR LAST AND FINAL
BILL WHICH IS FILE ITEM SEVEN SP
ELEVEN ELEVEN BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA WELCOME CENTER TO LET
YOU MAY BEGIN. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN ELEVEN. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE CHAIRMAN
OR COMMITTEE. AND HER STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME TO IMPROVE THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. THE RICK BEST
SAFETY ACT. IS NAMED AFTER
LONGTIME LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND
LOBBYISTS. RODRICK RICK BEST WHO
SADLY PASSED AWAY AFTER A
TRAFFIC ACCIDENT WITH AN
UNMARKED DUMPSTER. AND A VERY
VERY CLOSE FRIEND MY CHIEF OF
STAFF JOHN WILCOX. MAY HE REST
IN PEACE. THIS NECESSARY SAFETY
MEASURES WILL PROTECT THE LIVES
OF EVERYONE ON OUR ROADWAYS.
THIS COMMON SENSE MEASURE WILL
REQUIRE LARGE TRASH ROUTE
RECEPTACLES PLACED ON ROADWAYS
AND CURBS THEY HAVE REFLECTIVE
MARKINGS ON EACH SIDE. THIS
MARKING IS SO VITAL TO SAFETY.
WITHOUT REFLECTIVE MARKETING
THESE TRASH RECEPTACLES OR
INVISIBLE AT NIGHT. AND LIKELY
TO CAUSE FURTHER ACCIDENTS AND
EVEN DEATH. RICK WORK IN
SACRAMENTO AS A LEGISLATIVE
STAFFER AN ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTIVIST WHO WAS HIGHLY INVOLVED
WITH CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLING
MOVEMENT FOR MANY MANY YEARS AS
A LEGISLATIVE STAFFER RICK HELP
SHEPHERD THE DOZEN OF
ENVIRONMENTAL BILLS THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY INCLUDING A. B. TWENTY
TWO FOURTEEN WHICH PREVENTED.
CREATION OF RADIOACTIVE WASTE
DUMP IN THE BOBBY DEDRIC WARD
VALLEY HE CONTRIBUTED A GREAT
DEAL TO THIS GREAT BODY. HE
LATER WENT ON TO BECOME THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE WHERE HE WAS MOST
KNOWN FOR TAKING ON COCA COLA
MILLER BREWING COMPANY AND DOW
ARGO SCIENCES. MEMBERS PUBLIC
SAFETY AND KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE
ON OUR STREETS IS ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST PRIORITY. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN ELEVEN IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP. CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE TO
IMPROVE OUR ROADWAYS FOR
MOTORISTS AND BICYCLISTS ALIGHT.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT F PUBLIC HEALTH IN
2019404% A BICYCLE ACCIDENT AND
OUR STATE TOOK PLACE AT NIGHT.
IN MANY FIFTIES TRASH DUMPERS
AND ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL
HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION BETWEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AND
200-019-1600 AND SEVENTY TWO
TOTAL- CYCLISTS HAVE DIED. AND
CALIFORNIA STREETS WITH AN
AVERAGE OF A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
PEOPLE PER YEAR THE CYCLISTS
MUST BE CONTINUED TO BE
PROTECTED. LARGE TRASH
RECEPTACLES PLACED ON ROADWAYS
AND CURBS ARE VIRTUALLY IN
VISIBLE. ON DARK STREETS AND
THEY PRESENT A HAZARD TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. THE MAJORITY OF
THE OF THEM ARE DARK COLORED
OFTENTIMES WITH NO REFLECTIVE
STRIPES UNLESS THE COMPANY HAS
ADDED TO HIM AND SOME ARE TRYING
TO DO IT NOW. AS WE KNOW RICK
SCENARIO- THE DRIVER A BISON
RIGHT IN THE LONG RUN AT NIGHT
CAN POTENTIALLY RUN INTO ONE OF
THESE FULL SPEED AND BECOME
SERIOUSLY INJURED OR EVEN KILLED
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF RETRO
REFLECTIVE MARKETING TO ENHANCE
VISIBILITY. IT IS THERE FOR A
PURPOSE FURTHERMORE CALIFORNIA
ALREADY UTILIZED A REFLECTIVE
MARKETING ON OUR ROADS TRAFFIC
SIGN LICENSE PLATE JUST TO NAME
A FEW. S. P. ELEVEN ELEVEN SIX
TO IMPROVE NIGHTTIME VISIBILITY
ENABLING MORE REACTION TIME
WHICH WILL RESULT IN SAFER ROADS
FOR DRIVERS AND CYCLISTS AT
NIGHT. IT IS AN IMPORTANT REASON
THAT WE CONTINUE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY THAT WE'RE SPEAKING HERE
TONIGHT. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. WITH ME TODAY I HAD TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS COREY- SELVES IT IS YELLOW.
ON BEHALF OF THE THREE M.
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY DIVISION.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHER LET US
SO WE HAVE- COREY SOCIO WITH
THREE M. ON THE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE. I'M SORRY
EXCUSE ME ACTUALLY IN PERSON-
COREY SOCIO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
THREE M. TRANSPORTATION SAFETY
DIVISION I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN ELEVEN- AND IS THE
AUTHOR NOTED WE WOULD POINT TO
THE EFFICACY OF RETROREFLECTIVE
MARKINGS IN ENHANCING VISIBILITY
AND PROVIDING THOSE WHO USE OUR
ROADS. OUT WITH ADDITIONAL TIME
TO SEE- AND AVOID POTENTIAL
HAZARDS- AS THE AUTHOR NOTED
THERE ARE ALREADY ALREADY
REQUIREMENTS. TRAFFIC SIGNS
TRUCK TRAILERS RAILROAD CARS-
HAVE RICHER REFLECTIVE
PROPERTIES AND OTHER MARKINGS
ARE REQUIRED- TO HAVE
FLUORESCENT PROPERTIES- ADDING
THIS REFLECTIVE REQUIREMENT-
THESE TRASH RECEPTACLES- WOULD
BE A CLEAR DEMONSTRATION OF OUR
COMMITMENT TO ROADWAY SAFETY.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
SOCIO- SO YOU. HAVE NO OTHER
WITNESSES AND- TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT BUT WE WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN ELEVEN. SEE
NONE SO WE'LL MOVE ON MR
MODERATOR TO ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN ELEVEN PLEASE. THANK YOU
JUSTIFY AND SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN.
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR SB ELEVEN
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A
PURCHASE THE QUEUING UP.
EVERYBODY ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO
FOR THE OPERATOR GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER PERFECT. AND WE WILL LINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR OPEN. MANY
KATHY LYNCH REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA WASTE HAULERS
COMPOUNDS ALL OF TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING SOLID
WASTE HANDLING AND RECYCLING- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND
THE STAFF BUT IT COULD GET THE
BRAKE PADS WAS THAT. YOUR FRIEND
AND COLLEAGUE DAN IS WOULD BE
VERY PROUD TO BE LEADING PUBLIC
POLICY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AND
PLEASE SUPPORT. ONE FINE QUICK
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB.
ELEVEN ELEVEN. ELSE'S QUEUING UP
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR US WE'VE CONCLUDED
WITH A TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN
ELEVEN WILL START IN THE SENATE
GALLERY ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN ELEVEN. THE NINE MISTER
MODERATOR WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
YOU FOR ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LANE AND LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN ELEVEN PLEASE. THANK YOU
A LEGION GERMAN TEST. TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. OKAY THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR SWEET CONCLUDED
SUPPORT AN OPPOSITIONAL TAKE IT
BACK TO MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON AS P.
ELEVEN ELEVEN. SENATOR
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- CENTER OR TO LET IT WHAT
I. WHAT I'M I'M I'M CLEAR OF IN
YOUR BILL IS- IT'S NOT SPECIFIC
AS TO WHO WOULD- COLLECT THE
FINE. I'M SORRY WHAT WHO WHO
WOULD ACTUALLY WHO WOULD BE
COLLECTING THE FINDING WELL LET
ME POINT OUT THAT REMEMBER I'D
MENTIONED THAT THE
MUNICIPALITIES WOULD BE- FEEL
WELCOME TO SEE THIS THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT WOULD BE- IN CHARGE.
OF IN THE IN THE COURSE OF THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF- IS THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION IT'S JUST THE
EMPLOYMENT THE SAFETY ROLE AND I
THINK IT'S- IT'S EASY EASY FOR
US- THANK YOU AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT MY- MY QUESTION
NOW IS. WHO WHO IS COLLECTING
THAT FINE IF THE BUT SAY IT'S
YOU KNOW WHATEVER WASTE HAULING
COMPANY- IS LEASING THE TRASH
RECEPTACLES AND THEY DON'T HAVE
THOSE REFLECTIVE MARKINGS. THEN
WHO COLLECTS THE O. LINE FROM
THEM IT WOULD BE THE CITY IN
QUESTION AND THIS IS ALL YOU
WOULD. KEEP THAT MONEY THE CITY.
THE CITY WOULD BE IN CHARGE AIR
FORCE A AND THE FOLLOWING ARE
VERY MINIMAL THE MONEY WITH ITS
MORE OF A PUBLIC SAFETY
KNOWLEDGE AND- BECAUSE THE
FINDER. THE VERY FIRST OFFENSE
IS A HUNDRED DOLLARS- SECOND IS
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN THE
THIRD IS A THOUSAND RIGHT I JUST
I DIDN'T SEE IN THE BILL I
NOTICED WHERE YOU PULLED OUT THE
PART. THAT REFERENCE ON THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
AND SO I DIDN'T SEE IN THERE
THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT THE CITY.
IS THE ENTITY THAT WOULD COLLECT
THAT REVENUE IN KEEP IT AND WE
WILL WORK WITH THAT TO CLARIFY
THAT. BUT AGAIN IT'S JUST TO GET
THE PROGRAM MOVING AND I THINK
THAT- WE'RE NOT TRYING TO BE
PUNITIVE TO THE INDUSTRY WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO BRING THEM AROUND
. TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THAT
SO MANY CITIES OF AVAST FOR
INDIA BY TO LISTEN. AND DRIVERS
AT NIGHT IN RURAL AREAS
ESPECIALLY. BE VERY DANGEROUS.
AND I BELIEVE SENATOR ARCHER
LETTER THAT WAS TAKEN OUT FROM
THE BILL SO IT'S NOT- THERE'S
NO- CLEARER- DEFINITION ON WHO
WOULD ACTUALLY RECEIVE THE-
VIOLATION OR- WAS RECEIVED THAT.
ARE WHO WOULD ENFORCE AND
RECEIVE THE REVENUE ON ON THE-
VIOLATION. SO THAT COULD BE-
DISCUSSED MOVING FORWARD IN THIS
BILL AND I THINK THIS IS. NEXT
GOING TO JUDICIARY SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S VOTE COULD
BE TAKEN UP AT THAT POINT- THANK
YOU SENATOR MELENDEZ AND SENATOR
ARCHULETA ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SENATOR BATES ARE
YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR SENATOR
ARCHULETA MY UNDERSTANDING IS-
LET MANY CITIES HAVE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS WITH WASTE HAULERS.
WOULDN'T THAT BE SOMETHING THAT
THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO- REQUIRE-
WIND THEY NEGOTIATE THEIR THEIR-
THEIR AGREEMENTS WITH CITIES
THAT THESE PARTICULAR.
REFLECTIVE TAPES WHATEVER THE
USE FOR THE REFLECTIVE DEVICE BE
INCLUDED. ON THEIR LARGE.
DUMPSTERS OF THE LARGE
CONTAINERS- THAT WAY THERE WOULD
BE A WAY TO- ACTUALLY FOLLOW UP
ON WHO DID IT. IT IT IT DID NOT
DO IT. AND WHERE THE- PENALTIES
LION AND THAT COULD REALLY BE
VERY FOCUSED AT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL AND I THINK
EASILY TRACKED DOWN THAT IF THE
QUESTION. WAS PERHAPS THE
SUGGESTION. YES I THAT EVERY
THAT WE'RE A TO DO- WILL COME
FORWARD WORKING WITH THE TRASH
INDUSTRY MAKING SURE THAT- THAT
WHATEVER. OWNERSHIP OBVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW EVERY CITY HAS A
DIFFERENT COMPANY. AND FROM THE
INVESTIGATIVE WORK WE'VE DONE
THEY'RE ALL READY TO DO IT THEY
JUST WANT TO. HEAR FROM US THAT-
THE COMPULSION ARE PARTICIPATING
IN A MENTORED EARLIER A FEW OF
THEM ARE DOING IT. WE JUST GOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WORK HAND
IN HAND WITH THE CITY AND IT
COULD BE A CITY SEAL COULD BE
THE WRAPPING. BUT REFLECTIVE
THINGS THAT ARE NECESSARY WILL
BE SEEN AS THE AUTOMOBILE THE
BICYCLIST APPROACHES. THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. I'M NOT
I'M GOING TO JUST A NOTE BOOK
THIS MORNING THAT WORK WITH YOU
ON A FEW IDEAS I FEEL IT'S A
LITTLE MORE PRESCRIPTIVE. I
THINK THAT WILL HELP THEN IT
WILL ALSO HELP R. I THINK IN FOR
CEMENT AND FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE
PART OF OUR WASTE HAULERS. WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF IT THAT IS A
LITTLE VAGUE NOW. FOUND OUT OUT
OR BE CHATTING WITH YOU AFTER
VERY GOOD SENATOR BE WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT. THANK YOU VICE
CHAIR BASED SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MANAGERS. GENERAL TWO
AND A QUICK QUESTION- I NOTICED
THAT. IN THE RELATED PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION SECTION OF OUR HOUSE
IS. EITHER YOU DANCE NUMBERS
THIS BILL. NOT ONCE BUT TWICE
BEFORE- SO KUDOS FOR EUROPE
CONSISTENCY. ABOUT GEORGIA IN
BRIEF WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
BETWEEN THIS BILL IN THE
PREVIOUS TWO- THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IS ADDRESSING- THE SIGNAGE
AND ONLY THE SIGNAGE WRAPPING.
THAT'S IT IT IT DOESN'T. COVER
ANYTHING ELSE ONLY REQUIRING
THAT ALL THESE- DIFFERENT
COMPANIES. ADHERE TO THE RULE.
PLACE THE SIGNAGE AROUND YOUR
TRASH BINS REFLECTIVE- SO THE
MOTORIST AND CYCLIST COULD BE
AWARE OF SEEING THAT IN THE
EVENING HOURS OBVIOUSLY WHEN
IT'S DARK IN THIS IS WHAT CAUSED
THAT ONE ACCIDENT SO THIS IS TO
PREVENT. FURTHER ACCIDENTS. AND
SO THE INDUSTRY IS NOT. AGAINST
IT WE'VE HAD NO NEGATIVE ON IT
IT JUST IMPLEMENTING THE PLAN
AND I THINK IT'LL IT'LL COME
FULL CIRCLE WITHIN A SHORT TIME
. THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON SB
ELEVEN ELEVEN SEE NONE- CAN WE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE BILL
PLEASE. SENATOR SKINNER MOTIONS
SO- THIS IS DO YOU PASS TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MR XI
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. ON S. P. ELEVEN ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
ENTERS GONZALEZ HI IN DALLAS I
BAKES. ALAN HELEN HI WHICH
LETTER I OR JULY SECOND. BECKER
HI CORTESE CORTESE II DOLLY. DOT. HI THE MOMENT THE MON HI WHERE
CHOIR HI BELINDA'S. IN MINHAI
NEWMAN NEWMAN HI RUBIO. RUBIO I
GET IT. HI MY CASKET WHEN CASKEY
I WILL WE'LL KNOW. IN ONE.
THIRTEEN ONE THANK YOU MR TO
CONSULTANT OF THIRTEEN ONE AT
THIS POINT IT HAS ENOUGH TO GET
OUT THE LIFT THE CALL ON THIS
THANK YOU SENATOR LOU ARCHULETA
. OKAY MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT WAS VERY- EFFICIENT
MEETING WE'VE HAD SOME GREAT
DEALS AND SO NOW- WE'LL GO BACK
AND LIFT THE CALLS CONSULTANT
CAN YOU PLEASE LET THE CALL
STARTING WITH HER FIRST FILE
ITEM. WHILE ITEM ONE SP EIGHT
THIRTY SEVEN IS A CONSENT ITEM.
CENTRE ALAN. ELLEN HI BECKER THE
GIRL HI KELLY KELLY HI LAMONT.
HI WHERE. BY LENDERS ONE MOMENT
AS I BILL RUBIO I SCANNER. I.
OKAY SEVENTEEN ZERO THAT'S ON
FILE ITEM ONE CONSENT AS P.
EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN BY AMBERG IS
OUT THANK YOU MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
. SP EIGHT NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR JONES THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER THE CHAIR
AND THE VICE CHAIR BOTH VOTING
HI. ALAN ELLEN HI BECKER. BECKER
I. THE MOBILE. THE MON I REQUIRE
. BUT WHERE I WILL END THIS HI.
OKAY WE ALSO HAVE SEVENTEEN ZERO
FILE ITEM TO SB NINE FORTY TWO
BY SENATOR NEWMAN
CONGRATULATIONS I'LL MOVE ON. TO
MY APOLOGIES SENATOR JONES I
HAVE IT MIXED UP HERE IN THE
FILE SENATOR JONES
CONGRADULATIONS SEVENTEEN ZERO
AND THAT WOULD BE S. V. EIGHT
NINETY FOUR SO NOW WE'LL MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM THREE SP NINE FORTY
TWO BY SENATOR NEWMAN. ON S. B.
NINE FORTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY THE CHAIR AND THE VICE
CHAIR BOTH VOTING HI. SENATORS
ALAN ALAN HI BECKER. HI ALI. THE
MOAN MOAN HIGH WHERE THE CHOIR
HI BELINDA'S MELINDA'S HI. OKAY
WE HAVE SIXTEEN ZERO ON FILE
ITEM THREE SENATOR NEWMAN THAT
WAS S. B. NINE FORTY TWO WILL
MOVE ON TO SENATOR DODD'S BILL
THAT IS FILE ITEM FOR SP TEN
FORTY NINE. S. B. TEN FORTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR BILL FLOATING HIGH.
SENATORS ALANALAN HI BECKER
BECKER HIGH AMONG. MON HI WHERE
WHERE HI. LOOK WELCOME BYE. OKAY
THAT BILL GETS OUT SEVENTEEN
ZERO WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
FIVE SP TEN FIFTY BY SENATOR
DODD. S. B. TEN FIFTY EMOTIONS
DO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE THE CHAIR NOT VOTING THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS
ALAN ALAN HI BECKER BETTER HI
AMONG. WHERE WHERE I. MAN
SKINNER. CAN I KATHY MY CASKEY I
WILL WELCOME HI. ELEVEN OKAY
ELEVEN THREE THE BILL GETS OUT A
NOW MOVE ON TO SP. TEN SEVENTY
NINE BY SENATOR PORTENT TINO
THAT IS FLE ITEM SIX. S. B. TEN
SEVENTY THEM TEN SEVENTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. THE TRAVELING HI. THE
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING IT'S- ALAN. ALAN HI THE ONLY. THE MOMENT.
WELCOME. ONE TWELVE ONE THAT
BILL GETS OUT IN OUR FINAL BILL
SB ELEVEN ELEVEN BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA PILOT AND SEVEN. S. B.
ELEVEN ELEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY THE CHAIR
VOTING HI THE CHAIR NOT VOTING
VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING. IT'S
DOLLY. BELINDA'S. THE THIRTEEN
ONE THAT BILL GETS OUT THANK YOU
SO WE'VE CONCLUDED ALL OF OUR
BILLS- MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOU YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS WE
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS WELL THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON.
TRANSPORTATION IS INJURED.